Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie geht's? Sag mal, bist du gesund?
Nicht so ganz, deswegen bin ich nicht bei dir.
In diesen Zeiten.
Was hast du denn?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen. Ich habe mich vor allem unterkühlt, während ich auf Bahnhöfen stand und wartete, dass der Zug kommt. Ich habe wirklich ein bis zwei Stunden zum Teil gewartet, draußen auf dem Gleis im Wind, im Dunkeln und habe gewartet in Stuttgart, in Witten. Ich war ja viel unterwegs in den letzten Wochen und irgendwann habe ich wohl einen Knacks bekommen, wie man so sagt. So sagt es auch der Hausarzt und meinte dann, ja, da können sie sich noch mit Masken und so weiter schützen. Es gibt ja noch was anderes als Corona und da hat es irgendwie zugeschlagen mit Ohrenschmerzen und so weiter. Aber ich dachte mir, Podcast aufzeichnen können wir dennoch. Gern hätte ich natürlich mit dir heute ein Schnitzel gegessen, aber ich dachte, da müssen wir uns jetzt ein bisschen noch begnügen, dass wir, na ja, es wäre jetzt sehr unvernünftig, trotzdem zu dir zu kommen und dich vielleicht noch mit irgendwas anzustecken. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, inwieweit das jetzt hier ansteckend ist oder inwieweit einfach der Körper gerade sich bei mir beschwert über das, was ich ihm angetan habe mit all den Bahnfahrten.
So soll es also sein. Das stellt sich da ja sehr schnell heraus. Wenn man so denkt, dann ist das für kleine Geschäftsinhaber eigentlich nichts, denn die können sich das überhaupt nicht leisten, ein Cirque du Soleil zu veranstalten. Das ist dann eher was für die großen Häuser, für Luxuskaufhäuser wie Breuninger oder so. Und wenn man sich dann mal so ein bisschen durch YouTube klickt und sich Podcasts anhört zu den Innenstädten, wie sie sich verwandeln sollen oder einfach mal so ein bisschen Fernsehen guckt, dann merkt man, ja, so etwas geht das schon in die Richtung. Und das ist mal aus einer Art Doku jetzt über die Zukunft der Innenstadt.
Cross Selling heißt, durch Kundenbeziehungen mehr Produkte zu einem Thema zu verkaufen. Eine Idee von L&T, ein Fitnessstudio mitten im Kaufhaus. Der eigentliche Publikumsmagnet, eine Surfwelle im Kaufhaus. Normalerweise können hier Surfbegeisterte jeden Tag Unterrichtsstunden und Surfzeit buchen.
Die Welle für sich rechnet sich nicht. Die Baukosten inklusive die Betriebskosten sind dann schon enorm. Es ist ein Highlight und sorgt für Frequenz. Und so sind die ganzen Cross Selling Verkäufe, die wir haben, im ganzen Unternehmen. Die sorgen dann eben für die Rentabilität des Gesamtkonzeptes.
Ja, da hatten wir durch Zufall den selben Clip. Denn ich habe das auch gesehen. Ich habe gedacht, das kann ja nicht wahr sein. Aber ja, in Münsten gibt es einen Sportladen, der im Keller im Erdgeschoss einfach eine Surfwelle hat. Ja, das ist also fünf Meter breit oder was und zwölf Meter lang. Und dann fließt da Wasser und es ist genau eine so eine Senke. Und dann kann man da surfen. Dann machen die da irgendwelche Wettkämpfe und so. Jetzt gerade außer Betrieb, weil Corona und so. Aber das geht natürlich wirklich nur als das Leuchtturmprojekt. Und das dann aber auch alle anderen wieder wegmarginalisiert. Also wenn man so im Umfeld wahrscheinlich wird man noch in Osnabrück da sitzen und denken, was machen wir heute? Ich brauche neue Sportsachen. Komm, dann fahren wir lieber nach Münster. Also da kann er kannabalisiert sich die Region noch selber weg, weil der Münsterladen selbst in Osnabrück noch Schachmats setzt. Sobald man dann aber gefunden hat, was man braucht, holt man sich, wenn man es dann noch mal braucht, wie du deine Creme wahrscheinlich, dann doch online. Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob das so zieht mit dieser Surfwelle.
Ich glaube, alle gehen mal hin und alle gucken mal. Und hin und wieder kaufen dann Leute, auch gerade weil sie froh sind, etwas. Aber wenn man es mal gesehen hat, kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das auf Dauer Leute anzieht, beziehungsweise Activity-Möglichkeiten gibt es ja auch sonst. Also dafür muss ich ja vielleicht dann wirklich nicht in eine Innenstadt gehen. Zumal ich ja in einer Innenstadt auch entsprechend gekleidet bin, vielleicht noch abends was essen gehe oder so. Also ich glaube, das ist nicht die richtige Möglichkeit auf Dauer, dass man da so ein bisschen Spielplatz draus macht. Hanau geht jedenfalls einen anderen Weg. Das habe ich in einem hr-Beitrag gesehen. Die Ratgeber heißt der Beitrag.
Hanau, die kleinste Großstadt Hessens, an einem Samstag im Spätherbst. Wie immer wird Musik gemacht in der Fußgängerzone. Dafür sorgt die Stadt. Den Leuten soll es Spaß machen, herumzubummeln und zu shoppen.
Hanau hat ja auch sehr große Probleme, was die Klassenfrage betrifft. Also man hat da eine sehr unterschiedliche Bevölkerung, hat dort ja auch mit Rassismus erhebliche Probleme, wie wir vermutlich erst so richtig wissen, seit dem rechtsextremen Anschlag. Aber Hanau ist also eine Stadt, die irgendwie versucht, jetzt ein bisschen Kultur in die Stadt zu bringen oder zu erkennen, gut, das muss jetzt ein bisschen attraktiver werden, zum Beispiel dadurch, dass in irgendeiner Weise Kunst gefördert wird. Und das tut man dann auch, indem man Straßenmusik fördert. Wir können mal weiterhören, was dann da sich noch in den Geschäften tut.
Leerstände, immer mehr Nagelstudios, Friseure oder Billigshops, große Ketten. So eine Verödung soll es in Hanau nicht geben. Ganz neu auch der Vintage-Schlermotten-Laden von Noah Naber. Genau wie Leroy's, ein Pop-up-Store, den die Hanauer Innenstadtplaner hier haben wollten.
Vintage-Mode, dazu kommen wir gleich noch, aber jedenfalls ist das auch häufiger jetzt in Städten anzutreffen, dass man es mit Pop-up-Stores zu tun bekommt, die dann für drei Monate da sind und wieder verschwinden und dann kann man wieder auf was Neues warten.
Das finde ich macht es aber auch interessant. Ja. Das sehe ich ja in Frankfurt auch. Ab und zu gibt es immer wieder so ein Bubble Tea-Laden oder so. Ich frage mich dann immer, wie man es organisiert, denn man will ja doch schon sein Geschäftsmodell irgendwie auf Dauer stellen, finde dann da nicht statt. Aber das ist so dieses typische...
Na ja, es geht dadurch, dass man dann wieder das Ganze ans Internet anbindet. Das ist eigentlich der Witz dabei, dass ganz viel dort angeboten wird, was man dann im Internet, also was man dort testet. Man probiert mal dieses besondere Popcorn und kann es dann im Internet kaufen. Also eigentlich ist auch hier wieder ganz klar, das ist noch so ein Testareal, dass man vielleicht für Produkte, die noch nicht etabliert sind, braucht. Aber eigentlich ist der Weg dann auch wieder ins Internet, denn anders wäre das auch rechnerisch gar nicht leistbar. Also wenn man jetzt denkt, der Pop-Up-Store ist so erfolgreich, jetzt mache ich mal 500 Filialen auf in Deutschland, das wird schon wieder nicht mehr funktionieren. Also ist nur wirklich skalierbar dieser Erfolg dann, indem man es doch wieder ins Netz verlagert.
Ja, ist halt immer heikel zu organisieren. Ich denke mir immer, wenn man so einen großen Laden hat, was weiß ich, so wirklich so einen Galeria-Kaufhof oder so, da hast du die fünf Stockwerke und kannst auf einem Stockwerk so ein bisschen spielen. Weißt aber, die Leute kommen eigentlich auch wegen den anderen Stockwerken. Während die Städte selber, wie ich schon gesagt, immer keine Handhaber darüber haben, an wen man als nächstes vermietet. So, und das habe ich dann in Bielefeld erlebt, wo so ganze Straßenzüge sich plötzlich verwandeln in nur noch Wettbüros und so was. Also wo es super, da werden die Schaumfilter dann abgeklebt, man sieht gar nichts mehr. Dann wird da so ein bisschen Umsatz mit irgendwelchen Wetten gemacht. Und das ist super unattraktiv, durch solche Gegenden zu laufen, wo du einfach gar nichts mehr mitbekommst. Und die Städte haben eben nicht wirklich Handhaber darüber. Da einfach mal mitzuentscheiden. Man hat ja immer diese Idee aus Norwegen, die sich nie verifizieren ließe, aber er hat es so als Idee vorgebracht, dass man da eben nicht mehr nach höchstbietend versteigert. Und das wäre bei Deutschland völlig unverstellbar, dass man diese erste Büroetage laden, man kann aus der Straße heraus hineingehen, dass man das nicht höchstbietend macht in Deutschland. Also da wüsste ich gar nicht, ob es da irgendwie Gesetze gibt, die das noch regeln. Dass da Städte einfach mal eine Handhabe haben, die gibt es einfach nicht. Und dann hat man halt das Problem, alle drei Monate verwandelt sich so eine Stadt und wenn man nicht genau hinschaut, hat man ein Jahr später irgendwie so zugeklebte Schaufenster.
Ja, wir hören mal weiter.
Also wir gucken, was kann man in der Innenstadt tun, damit die Menschen auch nach wie vor gerne in die Innenstadt kommen. Da geht es jetzt eben nicht nur klassisch um Einkaufen. Die Menschen sollen ja nach drei Monaten auch wiederkommen und idealerweise an dieser Ecke, jetzt wo wir hier stehen, vielleicht dann ein anderes Konzept finden. Das ist unsere Idee. Wir wollen immer wieder Überraschungsmomente schaffen in der Innenstadt.
Drei Monate können die Newcomer ihr Konzept ausprobieren. Die Stadt unterstützt ihren Staat mit günstigen Mieten.
Also hier wird das ein bisschen subventioniert, aber es ist für mich nach wie vor die Frage, aber wie sieht jetzt eine Stadt in acht Jahren aus? Also was ist das für eine Perspektive? Ich kann natürlich jetzt in so einzelnen Läden sagen, hier ist jetzt Pop-up-Store und hier wechselt das alle drei Monate. Aber es geht ja auch darum, ob man eine Stadt dauerhaft attraktiv gemacht bekommt, dadurch, dass Menschen sich da ansiedeln mit ihren Geschäften und sagen, hier kann ich gutes Geld verdienen und hier ist es auch ansonsten lebenswert. Und das passiert ja nicht durch solche Modelle. Und man fragt sich auch, was machen diese Pop-up-Store-Leute, also die, die dann ihre Idee da vorgebracht haben, die ziehen dann in die nächste Stadt. Also das ist ja auch so ein vagabunden Dasein, dass man da... Jaja, also das läuft natürlich darauf hinaus, also dann ist man irgendwann so der Artist, der mit dem Zirkus durch die Gegend zieht. Also es ist schon fraglich, also natürlich passiert da was, aber es ist auch ein bisschen ein Hyperaktivismus und Pseudoaktivismus, der da zu beobachten ist. Ob das dauerhaft die Stadt verändern kann, das glaube ich eher nicht. Also ich glaube, es muss eigentlich eine Entkommerzialisierung der Stadt stattfinden. Also dass man einfach sagt, ja, Kommerz läuft jetzt ganz viel einfach über online und das ist auch oft sehr praktisch und kann uns sehr helfen. Wichtig ist dann nur, dass die Leute, die es bringen, vernünftig bezahlt werden, dass da alles stimmt und da ist ja noch einiges zu tun. Aber dass man sagt, warum soll man solche Orte nicht auch ganz anders nutzen? Und da, glaube ich, greifen diese Konzepte zu kurz bzw. vielleicht geht es so langsam die richtige Richtung, wenn man auch noch das Meer öffnet für die Kunst.
Wir müssen die Uniformität unserer Innenstädte aufbrechen.
Wir haben unsere Innenstädte an Filialisten verkauft.
Die Innenstädte sehen alle gleich aus.
Das Tacheles, ein Laden für und mit Kunst, mitten in der Fußgängerzone, ist für ihn ein gutes Beispiel.
Mit so einem Projekt ist es wichtig, den Leuten Raum zu geben.
Also lokal produzierende Künstler oder kleine Gold- und Silberschmieden eine Möglichkeit zu geben, ihr Tun einfach mal zu zeigen.
Die Idee ist ja...
Da bin ich total dafür.
Ja, absolut. Und das muss dann auch einfach von der Stadt mitfinanziert werden, denn das kann sich nicht rechnen. Die Idee ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen wie bei den Laguioll-Messern. Also da kann man ja auch dann dahin fahren und sieht dann, wie diese Messer kreiert werden. Und dann ist das etwas ganz Besonderes. Dann hat man ein Einkaufserlebnis und hat damit dann auch ein Stück Geschichte gekauft. Das kann man natürlich jetzt nicht überall herstellen, diese Historie. Da hat ja Boyd Hanski und Anno Esquer haben da ein sehr langes Buch drüber geschrieben, Bereicherungsökonomie, wie man also die Geschichte so ausschlachtet, um dann so ein Unix-Selling-Point für die Stadt zu kreieren. Aber generell denke ich auch, dass das eine Möglichkeit ist, dass also die Stadt viel mehr als Ort der Kultur auch begriffen wird.
Ich kann dir ja mal, du hast ja, also wir haben ja dieselbe Artel-Doku da gesehen, mit diesen Münsterranen, mit der Welle im Keller. Ich habe dann noch ein bisschen weiter geguckt und dachte, vielleicht habe ich hier einen Treffer, den du noch nicht kennst. Galileo, wer kennt es nicht? ProSieben, Galileo. Ich kann es schon nicht mehr, aber bei ProSieben was noch zu finden. Sie haben ja mal einen Besuch in Süddeutschland gemacht.
Das ist er, der schönste Supermarkt der Welt, gekrönt mit dem Euroshop Retail Design Award.
Ein Gourmet-
und Event-Tempel im baden-württembergischen Bad Krozingen, in dem alles etwas anders ist.
So, Bad Krozingen, noch nie gehört, aber da ist der schönste Supermarkt der Welt. Was natürlich bedeutet, also er war ein großer Edeka, der marginalisiert und kanibalisiert natürlich alle anderen im Umfeld irgendwie weg. Also wer am Wochenende schön einkaufen gehen will, geht dahin und findet dann beispielsweise Folgendes.
Wichtig ist, das Gesamtkonzept muss aufgehen und wenn der Gesamtmarkt ertragreich ist, dann ist das okay.
Auch dieses Eventhighlight rechnet sich bislang nicht, lockt aber neugierige Kunden sogar von weit her. Die erste Supermarktbrauerei Deutschlands. Hier braut Hieber sein eigenes sogenanntes Marktbier. Der Kunde kann bei kostenlosen Führungen erleben, wie das genau funktioniert.
So, der hat also eine Brauerei eingerichtet und während du jetzt darüber sprachst, wie man Innenstädte ummodeln kann, da dachte ich so ein bisschen, warum fahre ich mit meinen Kindern eigentlich auf irgendwelche Burgen, und zwar eine dreiviertel Stunde oder so mit dem Auto zu fünf, warum fahren wir zu Weihnachten oder im Winter zu irgendwelchen Burgen, um uns irgendwelche Mittelalterfeste anzugucken. Ja, da gibt es dann auch was zu kaufen. Man kauft bestimmt auch irgendwas, ne? Aber man sieht halt vor allem, wie es so gemacht wird, weil da werden dann Zelte vor dem Dings aufgebaut und in der Burg selbst wird die Küche mal wieder in Betrieb genommen und auf offenen Feuer gekocht und so weiter. Und da will man einfach dabei sein, das will man dann erleben. So, und warum nutzt man nicht diese Möglichkeit, Attraktivität zu schaffen, auch in Supermärkten? Dass man einfach sagt, hier ist die Bäckerei, da kann man auch durchgehen, da gibt es auch eine Führung, da ist die Brauerei, die gibt es sonst nie. Wir haben mal eine eingerichtet. Und jetzt sagen die ja in dem Bericht, rechnet sich aber nicht für den Supermarktbetreiber, wo ich mir wiederum denke, aber warum ist das denn das Problem des Supermarktbetreibers? Wieso rechnet er das nicht einfach irgendwo ab? Oder setzt das von der Steuerhabe oder wie auch immer?
Und so wird es ja auch sein, er schlägt es auf die Preise drauf und dann rechnet es sich.
Genau, aber warum ist das nicht kommunale Aufgabe, eine Brauerei zu betreiben? Oder jemanden, der das macht, ihn dabei wirtschaftlich so zu unterstützen, dass er das aus seiner eigenen BWL-Kalkulation rausnimmt? Wir freuen uns ja auch immer, dass Ikea so krass attraktiv ist, auch für Kinder, weil man da nochmal so einen tollen Kuchen essen kann und so weiter. Und diese Form der Publikumsbespaßung, die wird bei so Mittelalterfesten natürlich von den lokalen Tourismuseinrichtungen und so weiter unterstützt. Da stehen die Städte dahinter und sagen, wir wollen, dass auf der Dingsterbums, Falkenburg oder wo auch immer, dass das da weiter so in Betrieb ist. Und das könnte man ja eigentlich bei solchen, also da könnte man den Supermärkten auch unterstützen, indem man sagt, in dem Maße, wie Amazon hier keine Steuern bezahlt, geben wir euch auch Spielräume für das ein oder andere, was dann die Attraktivität wirklich steigert. Also hier geht man glaube ich zu wenig Hand in Hand.
Aber glaubst du, dass das wirklich zu regeln wäre?
Ich könnte mir eine Franken oder Innschlag ganz im Grunde sein.
Wenn jetzt jeder Supermarkt irgendwas will und dann sagt jeder, naja, wenn man was bekommt, dann stellen wir auch noch eine Hüpfburg draußen auf.
Genau, da muss man dann genau gucken, braucht man noch eine Hüpfburg oder nicht. Also hier in diesem Fall würde ich sagen, das ist jetzt zu nah an den Supermarkt angebunden und so weiter. Aber wir haben die großen Museen in Frankfurt, die es natürlich auch gefördert bekommen, wenn sie die Möglichkeit anbieten, Kindergeburtstage in Ateliers zu feiern, sodass man nicht nur das fertige Kunstwerk sieht mit seinem Kind, sondern sozusagen die leere Leinwand und die Farbpalette. Und dann darf einfach jeder sich da mal austoben. Das könnte man über Eintrittspreise nicht abdecken. Da braucht man einfach eine Förderung. Und diese Kunsthäuser kriegen solche Förderung. Diese Konsumtempel, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob man da, ob da nicht noch mehr Eingriffsmöglichkeit, Förderbedarf, Attraktivitätsgewinnung ist, den man einfach ausnutzen kann. Oder ob eben wirklich jeder letzte Quadratmeter, das ist ja mal ganz erstaunlich. Also die MileZile in Frankfurt ist ausgelegt für sehr viele Leute, die da durchlaufen. Und umso weniger Leute durchlaufen, umso mehr werden noch so kleine Ecken am Geländer, wo man noch mal so drei Quadratmeter findet. Zwischen Ladenecke, um die man rumläuft, und Einstieg in die Rolltreppe oder so, werden dann auch noch mal aufbereitet für irgendwas Kleines, wo man was kaufen kann, wo noch jemand einen Stand für Säfte oder sonst irgendwie hat. Und da denke ich mir immer, warum wird das jetzt noch mal für Cashflow optimiert und nicht für andere Sachen, die irgendwie für alle so ein bisschen besser werden.
Und dann müsste man sich sehr aus dem Kommerziellen der Stadt lösen. Also da müsste man sagen, die Stadt ist jetzt erstmal ein Ort der Begegnung oder wie man das auch dann immer nennen möchte.
Dafür braucht man eine große Querfinanzierung. Wenn man so ein Unternehmen wie Biontech hat, die die ganze Welt mit irgendwas versorgen und darüber laufen Steuern in die Stadt ein, dann muss man nicht Biontech die Steuerlast senken, die machen genug Umsatz. Also das ist jetzt nicht, dass Mainz vorher einen unfairen Steuersatz hatte und deswegen jetzt so viel bezahlt wird, sondern nein, da lief einfach ein Geschäft gut. Und jetzt ist die Stadt eigentlich dafür da, würde ich sagen, um hier Querfinanzierung zu ermöglichen. Also Steuereinnahme hier, Steuerausgaben da, um die Stadt attraktiv zu halten. Aber nein, man senkt für Biontech die Preise und möchte dann, dass im Einkaufstempel auch noch jeder Quadratmeter für Konsum genutzt wird. Und das treibt die Leute aber aus der Stadt heraus. Also ich werde nie wieder so in die Stadt.
Genau, und das Leben in der Stadt ist natürlich extrem teuer. Also Leben in der Stadt, du hast es gerade beschrieben, mit der Familie ins Museum zu gehen und schon sind 60 Euro weg. Das ist ähnlich, wenn man sagt, wie komme ich überhaupt dahin? Fahr ich mit den Öffentlichen? Ist es teuer? Fahr ich mit dem Auto? In Düsseldorf zahle ich im Parkhaus 24 Euro dann, wenn ich da gestanden bin. Also das sind ja einfach absurde Preise, womit man natürlich auch eine Exklusivität herstellt. Denn alle, die sich das nicht leisten können, die kommen dann erst gar nicht. Aber dass man eine Stadt auch so begreift, dass da eigentlich alle auch Platz finden sollen, wird überhaupt nicht mehr vorausgesetzt. Und zu fragen ist ja auch, kann es eigentlich sein, dass ich immer nur essen und trinken kann, wenn ich in irgendwelche Ketten gehe, mal von den paar Restaurants, die es dann noch frei gibt, abgesehen, wieso gibt es nicht auch Möglichkeiten, wo man sich, jetzt haben wir gerade eine Pandemie, ist es schlecht, aber wo man sich auch in Innenräumen treffen kann, nicht nur in der Bibliothek zum Bücher lesen, sondern dass man auch irgendwo sitzen kann, sich mit Freunden trifft, jeder bringt zwei Flaschen mit, trinkt da zusammen, ohne dass man dann zu den entsprechenden Ketten gehen muss, ohne dass nur die Leute an der Stadt partizipieren können, die viel Geld haben. Also das ist sehr, sehr eigenartig.
Genau, nehmt ihr zum Beispiel das Schauspiel Frankfurt. Großes Haus, weltberühmt, tolles Ensemble und so weiter. Wenn du da sonntag morgens mit deinen Kindern irgendwie hingehst, ich war noch nie da, sonntag morgens mit den Kindern, weil man kriegt nie Karten. Das liegt auch daran, dass man keine Karten kriegt, dass die Karten nicht besonders teuer sind. Und man weiß irgendwie, ja, so vier, fünftel des Preises hier wird subventioniert. Die Stadt bezahlt sehr viel dafür, damit wir die Möglichkeit haben, mit Kindern irgendwie morgens da mal hinzugehen. Das sind irgendwie 15 Euro die Karte oder so, keine Ahnung. Man weiß aber eigentlich, werden es 100. So, warum gibt es diese Art der Förderung? Nicht auch für alle anderen Häuser. Warum muss es immer, wenn man schon subventioniert in die Stadt geht, dann ist es die Hochkultur. Warum nicht, sich den anderen Häusern auch mal zuwenden und zu sagen, Frankfurt hat tolle Gewerbeeinnahmen, hier gibt es tolle Unternehmen, die verdienen alle sehr viel Geld. Und dafür machen wir jetzt die Stadt wirklich mal interessant, um auch, und das ist ja eigentlich immer das große Ziel, weil man fragt sich auch, was hat man jetzt davon, wenn man Frankfurt attraktiv macht. Mir geht es ja auch immer darum, jetzt wirklich eine langfristige Lösung zu finden. Wir sehen, wie es in Japan nicht funktioniert, aber das zentrale Ziel ist auch bis Ende des Jahrhunderts, das Land entvölkert zu kriegen und alle in die Stadt zu holen. Die Stadt muss so attraktiv sein, dass wir die Ländereien zwischen den Städten wirklich wieder an die Natur zurückgeben können, ohne da in irgendwelche Wälder einzugreifen, noch den Forstbestand und so weiter. Sondern das Ziel ist Ende des Jahrhunderts nur noch Städte, leben nur noch in Städten. Und wenn jemand meint, er will aber wie auf dem Land leben, dann muss man wie auf dem Land leben, aber in der Stadt. Das ist das ultimative Ziel. Und das könnte man jetzt beginnen, indem man in diesem Maße über die Attraktivität der Innenstädte nachdenkt und nicht kleine BWL-Rechnungen mit irgendwelchen Hebesätzen auf Gewerbsteuer macht und so. Also sehr enttäuschend, was da meins passiert.
Wir blicken nach Kassel zu Karstadt.
Anders als in Kassel, wo die Rede vom regionalen Magneten ist. Denn hier soll den Kunden jede Menge Service geboten werden, damit sie sich im Warenhaus dort wohlfühlen, unter anderem in Zusammenarbeit mit der Stadt Kassel.
So, was macht die Stadt Kassel jetzt mit Karstadt zusammen?
Stefan Hill, Filialeiter von Galleria Kassel, erzählt.
Sie kommen bei uns rein und sagen, ich möchte zum Beispiel bei der Stadt einen Führerschein abholen, ich möchte ein Führungszeugnis dem ins Speer antragen. Das können Sie alles bei uns in diesem Service-Hat aktivieren und im engen Schulterschluss natürlich auch mit der Stadt Kassel. Weil die natürlich auch sagen, naja, unsere Kunden, die kommen meistens ins Rathaus so bis 14, 16 Uhr bei uns, das Warenhaus hat von 10 bis 20 Uhr geöffnet.
Damit soll die Stadt den Bürgern näher rücken, sagt er. Und nicht nur mit der Stadt Kassel gibt es eine Kooperation, sondern auch mit Versicherungen und Paketdiensten.
Ja, sehr gut. Der One-Stop-Shop ist das Mega-Ding der Zukunft, der nächsten Jahrzehnte. Bis hin zur Impfung hoffentlich.
Das wäre auch noch schön, wenn man sich gerade da noch den Booster mitholen könnte, wie wir hier sagen. Sagt man das bei euch eigentlich auch? Wir holen alles mit. Kaffee zum Mitholen zum Beispiel.
Nee, das sagt man ja nicht.
Ja, das ist hier üblich. Wir nehmen nichts mit, wir holen alles mit. Man nimmt hier auch nicht drei Kilo ab, sondern man holt drei Kilo ab. So ein anderes Thema, was daran anschließt an die Innenstädte, ist natürlich, wie können die Innenstädte denn überhaupt das noch rechtfertigen, was da so an Mode verkauft wird. Es ist ja grauslich, wenn man liest, wie katastrophal es ist, wie sehr die Mode die Umwelt belastet. Also es gibt da vom Wissenschaftlichen Dienst des Europäischen Parlaments eine Zahl, 10 Prozent der Treibhausgasemissionen gehen auf die Mode zurück, also auf die Kleidung, die wir kaufen und dann sehr schnell wieder wegwerfen oder in die alte Kleidersammlung bringen. Es gibt ein Rundschreiben von Frontrunners der EU. Niederlande sind dabei, einige andere Länder, die sagen, wir müssen jetzt dringend nachhaltig werden, müssen das einfordern in den Lieferketten. Es muss da ganz klare Regeln geben, denn es heißt, der durchschnittliche EU-Bürger kauft 60 Prozent mehr Kleidung und behält sie nur halb so lange wie noch vor 15 Jahren.
Da bin ich unschuldig.
Da bist du unschuldig. Ich schweige mich zu dem Thema mal aus. Kann aber sagen, dass ich natürlich Dinge trage, die nicht so schnell aus der Mode kommen. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Also Anzüge sind doch Klassiker am Ende. Man erkennt schon, ist das jetzt ein 90er-Jahre-Schnitt oder nicht. Aber dennoch ist man da ein bisschen sicherer unterwegs als bei so Fast Fashion, wo man doch sehr schnell erkennt, das war der Trend von vor drei Monaten. Da gibt es natürlich Gegentrends zu. Und denen sollten wir uns jetzt mal gerade öffnen. Und zwar gibt es den Gegentrend Slow Fashion. Auch dazu gab es bei Arte eine interessante Doku.
Es ist die Entdeckung der Langsamkeit. Slow Fashion statt Fast Fashion. Mode, die transparent, nachhaltig und fair ist. Mit Entwürfen, die nicht jedem Trend hinterher rennen wollen.
Zeitlose Entwürfe, zum Beispiel von Merz B. Schwanen, eine alte Marke, die von einem Ehepaar wieder nach vorn gebracht wurde, die sich klassischen Looks verschrieben haben.
Gewisse Klassiker, die haben kein Verfallsdatum.
Die alten Rund-Wirk-Maschinen sind Slow Fashion im wahrsten Sinne. Fast eine Stunde brauchen sie für den Stoff eines Shirts. Läden und Händler haben bei den beiden in diesem Jahr so viel bestellt wie noch nie. Schon in vier Wochen muss die neue Herbst-Winter-Kollektion fertig sein.
Jede Größe hat ihre eigene Maschine. Das heißt, wenn eine ausfällt, dann kommen wir da wirklich ins Stocken, wenn es dann auf einmal keine M gibt.
Wir sehen jetzt aber schon das Paradoxe daran. Also Slow Fashion, aber diese Hersteller von Mode, die noch mit klassischen Schnitten arbeitet, mit alten Maschinen arbeitet. Diese Mode ist plötzlich sehr nachgefragt. Also kommt es da zu Stockungen. Das heißt, eigentlich müsste man jetzt diese Slow Fashion in Fast Fashion verwandeln, damit man der Nachfrage noch höher werden kann. Wird man nicht, also gibt es dann Limitierungen oder man muss lange drauf warten. Und ich frage mich da immer, ob dieses Paradoxe auf so einer volkswirtschaftlichen Eben auch erkannt wird. Denn betriebswirtschaftlich kann ich das natürlich genauso machen. Ich kann sagen, was gibt es noch nicht? Und erstmal stelle ich fest, in der Mode gibt es alles. Es gibt vor allem sehr viel Billiges zu kaufen. Für ganz, ganz wenig Geld bekomme ich Kleidersäcke voll. Aber was es vielleicht nicht gibt oder wenig gerade gibt, ist etwas, was sehr lange hält, was sich an keinen Trend orientiert und und und. Und dann wartet man und wartet und sagt, hier, das ist das neue Stück. Da haben wir jetzt zwei Jahre dran gearbeitet. Das bringen wir jetzt nun heraus. Nur volkswirtschaftlich bedeutet das einfach, es gibt da noch so eine Nische für solche nachhaltige Mode. Und die erschließt man sich gerade. Das heißt aber jetzt volkswirtschaftlich für das Ganze gesehen, nicht, dass sich dadurch die Mode in was Nachhaltiges unbedingt verändert, sondern es gibt so eine kleine Zielgruppe dafür, der Mode im Sinne von, was ist der neueste Trend, nicht wichtig ist.
Oder man macht Lokalfashion draus, dass man nicht mehr den großen zentralen super langsam Anbieter hat, sondern das so ein bisschen verteilt, darüber auch wieder Variantenreichtum reinbringt. Aber eben die Gewinner auch nicht zentralisiert, sondern das ist einfach, dann kann man Slow Fashion aus Frankfurt nur in Frankfurt kaufen.
Nur, du weißt ja, wie es ist mit dem Internet, da braucht nur ein Influencer das dann mal anzuhaben und schon fährt morgen alles mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt, 200 Kilometer, um dieses eine Teil dann auch zu kaufen. Es gibt etwas in dieser Art Doku, was auch interessant ist, Esket heißen die, das ist eine Modefirma, die sich auch darauf konzentriert, ganz wenige Teile herzustellen, möglichst keine Jahreskollektion herauszubringen, sondern ganz wenige Teile und die sollen dann eigentlich für immer stehen, so wie sie sind.
Seit sechs Jahren denken die beiden das Thema Mode radikal neu. Mit ihrem Label versuchen sie erst gar nicht Trends zu setzen. Im Gegenteil, je schlichter, desto besser. Der Fokus liegt auf Qualität, bei der Passform, den Materialien und der Produktion. August und Jakob sind keine Modedesigner, beide haben BWL studiert. Jetzt wollen sie eine ganze Industrie umkrempeln. Und das mit so wenig Kleidung wie möglich. Die neue Frauen-Kollektion von Designerin Darn startet mit gerade mal drei schlichten Teilen.
Also ich halte es da ganz mit Wolfgang Joop, der ja mal sagte, der Jugend steht das weiße T-Shirt am besten. Mode ist nur dafür da, um das Alter zu übertöntchen und die Unzufriedenheiten, die mit dem Alter einherkommen. Entsprechend gibt es sehr viele Menschen, die keine eigene Mode-Marke brauchen, um sich schlicht zu kleiden. Ich trage seit 15 Jahren dieselbe Hose. Wenn ich eine durchgelaufen habe, bestelle ich sie mir einfach nochmal.
Das heißt, du definierst dich immer noch als Jung im Sinne von Wolfgang Joop. Ich brauche nur ein weißes T-Shirt.
Ich bin jedenfalls nicht von mir so betrübt, dass ich mich irgendwie übertöntchen muss, sondern das ist das Standard-T-Shirt. Das habe ich bei Amazon mal gefunden von einer Marke, die es inzwischen nicht mehr gibt, leider. Aber ich habe noch 20 T-Shirts davon, reicht noch eine Weile. Und die Hose, die ich immer anhabe, die gibt es noch. Also in der Hinsicht bin ich fein raus bei diesem Thema.
Ja, und das Spiel mit der Mode ist also für dich überhaupt nie eine Frage, dass du sagst, darauf habe ich jetzt mal Lust, mal so auszusehen. Denn das ist ja auch was, was die Mode einem ermöglicht, dass man mal so, mal so wirkt.
Ich spiele selber nie mit der Mode, freue mich aber, wenn um mich herum mit Mode gespielt wird. Ja, also in der Hinsicht bin ich da sehr egoistisch.
Das verbindet dich ja auch mit einigen Mode-Machern, die immer gleich aussahen. Also Armani oder so, der immer dann in so einem schwarzen T-Shirt auftritt und damit aber nichts zu tun hat. Also er macht die Mode, er sieht diese permanente Verwandlung, aber er selbst verwandelt sich nicht. Gewisserweise ja auch Lagerfeld, der sich nicht verwandelt hat. Also der hat halt einmal diese Ikone sich dann geschaffen und dann war die Symbatik mal dünner, aber es gab keine Verwandlung. Es gibt dann natürlich andere Klamotten, ein bisschen andere Schnitte, die er getragen hat. Aber er hat sich jetzt nicht neu erfunden, sondern er blieb dann doch immer der Alte. Ich glaube, dass ich tatsächlich es mag, mit der Mode irgendwas zu spielen. Also nicht, dass ich das jetzt so groß, ich frage ja nicht, was will ich heute ausdrücken oder wie fühle ich mich oder so. Aber ich finde es einfach als eine, ich empfinde es als eine zivilisatorische Errungenschaft, dass man sich mit Zierde auseinandersetzen kann. Dass es also nicht nur um den Bedarf geht, denn grundsätzlich kann man auch im Zelt gut hausen, sondern dass man sagt, wie dekoriere ich mich selbst. Und das finde ich sehr schön und mag das auch tatsächlich sehr bei anderen und bin also immer jemand, der auch sagen würde, mehr ist mehr bei vielen Sachen. Also ruhig mal alles mögliche ausprobieren. Hier ist also dieser Gegentrend, dass man sagt, so ich brauche nur ein T-Shirt. Ich würde auch hier schon in Zweifel stellen, brauche ich dafür jetzt dieses Unternehmen Eskett, das mir jetzt dieses eine T-Shirt, diese eine Bluse entwirft. Da würde ich sagen, das gibt es schon. Also du hast es jetzt gerade gesagt, du hast da schon deinen Shirt gefunden. Und ich würde sagen, bei zum Beispiel den Unterhemden, die ich trage, die werden sich nicht mehr ändern. Die sind einfach sehr gut, so wie sie sind. Und da gibt es sowas schon. Das gibt es auch auf T-Shirt und Jeans Ebene. Da muss jeder nochmal selbst sehen, wie eng oder weit er es haben möchte. Aber eigentlich brauche ich dafür jetzt nicht nochmal extra ein Unternehmen. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass man, wenn man ein bisschen Geld ausgibt, also ein bisschen mehr als die 5, 99 Euro Klamotten, dann kann man auch sehr Haltbares finden. Also ich kann auch sogar sagen, dass ich Sachen von Zara viele, viele Jahre lang getragen habe und auch sehr intensiv getragen habe. Es ist keineswegs so, als löst sich das alles sofort in Luft auf, wenn man es zweimal anhatte. Aber es machen jetzt auch den ersten Laden. Also auch wieder sind wir hier beim Thema Innenstadt. So kann dann auch die Innenstadt aussehen. Wir sind hier fast schon wie in so einem Museum zum Anfassen.
Mit ihrem ersten Laden im Zentrum von Stockholm. Hier packen die Gründer einmal die Woche auch selbst mit an, verkaufen Klamotten und Gesinnung.
Das finde ich ja am besten ganz romantisch, wenn die Gründer nochmal selbst mit anfassen.
Ja, und wie ist denn das jetzt mit der Gesinnung, die hier verkauft wird? Du bekommst da mal so eine kleine Erklärung. Wo kommt denn eigentlich die Baumwolle her?
Es soll mehr als nur ein Geschäft sein.
Du kannst nicht einfach reinkommen, zwei T-Shirts kaufen und wieder gehen.
Wir wollen ins Gespräch kommen, das ganze Einkaufserlebnis entschleunigen.
Was wir dir hier zeigen wollen, ist die Reise von der Baumwollpflanze hin zu einer sauberen und gekämmten Baumwolle.
August erklärt erst mal, wo die Baumwolle für das Oxford-Hand herkommt und wie der Faden gesponnen wird.
Ganz schön viel Information für einen Kunden, der einfach nur ein Hemd braucht. Ganz schrecklich. Es ist die Dystopie für mich.
Dass du das erklärt bekommst. Ich kenne das nur aus der Luxus-Mode, also Luxus jetzt mal ein Anführungszeichen, aber wenn man sich jetzt ein Hemd machen lässt, was sich hin und wieder mal tat, dann bekommt man so Sachen erklärt. Und dann macht man das auch gern, weil man das ja mal wissen will. Und dann sagen die, nein, ich empfehle ihnen den Stoff, wenn sie viel sitzen und danach aufstehen, dann soll das Hemd nicht knittern. Deswegen ist es sinnvoller, das so zu wählen. Nehmen sie diese Knöpfe, diese Knöpfe kommen da und dort her. Da bekommt man das, aber das ist tatsächlich eher so aus dem besseren Konsum, wo man dann auch bei der Ernährung, bei Nahrungsmitteln, nochmal genau erklärt bekommt, wo ist jetzt dieser Käse eigentlich her oder wo ist dieser Wein her, wie wird er gekältet und so weiter.
Also beim konsumistischen Kümmern um sich selbst, finde ich, gibt es einen ganz großen Unterschied, richtig zwei Welten. Das eine ist alles, was personal und so weiter ist, wie zum Beispiel der Besuch beim Friseur. Man geht nicht einfach zum Friseur, sondern man geht zu seinem Friseur. Und Leute, die keinen festen Friseur haben, aber trotzdem regelmäßig sind, das verstehe ich immer nicht sowas. Und dann gibt es genau auf der anderen Seite des Spektrums, das ist für mich der Klamottenkauf. Sofern er überhaupt mal offline stattfindet, ich gehe das gerade so durch in meinem Kopf. Also ich simuliere jetzt viel in meinem Kopf, wie ich es mir vorstelle. Wenn ich in einen Laden gehe, will ich dort nicht angesprochen werden. Ich will nicht mal ablehnen, Hilfe zu brauchen, sondern ich möchte gar nicht belästigt werden. Am liebsten hätte ich so einen Punkt auf der Schulter, dass jeder sieht, der guckt sich hier um. Wenn er nichts kauft, ist das so. Fängt bloß nicht an, sich in den Weg zu stellen oder ihn anzusprechen. Und diese Idee, dass man das, was du gerade beschreibst, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen, wenn man sagt, wichtiger Termin, jetzt brauche ich doch mal einen Anzug. Also ich sag mal mal, was weiß ich, irgendeine Veranstaltung, wo man doch mal so ein 500 Euro Klamottenbudget hat und denkt, das nutze ich jetzt auch mal. Dann würde ich in so einem Laden anrufen und sagen, ich komme dann und dann und bitte seien Sie da nicht überrascht, ach Sie sind jetzt da, okay und so, sondern begrüßen Sie mich dann. Also ich bin dann einfach wirklich da. Sie wissen dann schon, was ich will und wie ich heiße und so. Dann kann ich mir das vorstellen. Und jetzt gibt es aber diesen Trend dazwischen, dass man sich in so einem Laden anmeldet, in so eine lange Terminliste einträgt und dann das Personal-Shopping-Erlebnis macht, für den Aufschlag ganz konkret 50 Euro. Also man geht zu Galeria Kaufhof und sagt, ich hätte gern den 10 Uhr-Slot für Personal-Shopping, 10 bis 11 Uhr, ich suche das und das. Und da weiß ich noch nicht so genau, ob das funktioniert. Weil das ist so in der Schwebe zwischen diesem, ich möchte in einen super Hyper-Store gehen, wo es alles gibt und was ich da nicht finde, gibt es dann auch nicht und da lohnt sich dann auch keine Beratung. Oder dieses ganz persönliche, ich gehe zum Friseur. Also vielleicht liegt da noch irgendwo eine Chance, aber so wie die das hier bei ihrem Asket-Laden gerade vorgeschlagen haben, dass sie mir erklären, wo die ihre Wolle her haben, ne, also da bin ich totaler Verfechter eines Lieferkettengesetzes. Ich möchte, dass da ein Zertifikat dranhängt, beglaubigt von der Bundesregierung. Dieser Laden ist safe, wir haben das hier kontrolliert.
Und du willst die Reise nicht nochmal mitmachen.
Auf eine Erzählung würde ich mich da nie einlassen, die können mir sonst was erzählen. Ich meine, mit irgendwelchen Erzählungen werden den Leuten gerade im Supermarkt einzelne Mandelnüsse für zwei Euro verkauft, nur weil die mit Wasser aufgelöst sind. Und das ist einfach unglaublich. In was für eine Realität wir leben. Leute kaufen irgendwie Wasser, dass sie genau so gut aus dem Wasserhahn kaufen könnten, das aber zwingend irgendwie bei Vitel in der Schweiz abgepumpt werden muss, sodass sie da alle Grundwasser-Sorgen haben. Das kriegt man alles irgendwie toll erzählt. Das ist das beste Wasser der Welt und so. Aber das ist alles Schwachsinn. Also in der Hinsicht sowas wie bei Ascade in den Laden gehen und dann erstmal, also wir möchten mit ihnen ins Gespräch kommen. Nee, das wäre für mich. Wenn das die Ansage ist, funktioniert bei mir genau nicht. Dann gehe ich da niemals hin.
Vielleicht aber möchtest du etwas in Zahnung geben und sagst, jetzt habe ich dieses gute Kleidungsstück, diesen tollen Anzug mir machen lassen. Oder, naja, machen lassen, da wird es ein bisschen schwer. Aber sag mal, du hast dir einen guten Anzug gekauft und jetzt war der Anlass da. Jetzt sagst du, bis da mal wieder ein Anlass kommt, da sehe ich nichts. Und jetzt kannst du in Kaufhäuser gehen und kannst dort Mode in Zahlung geben. Also wir können zum Beispiel sehen, dass du zu Breuninger gehen könntest und dort bringst du dann seine Sachen zurück. ZDF heute hat das auch mal aufgegriffen.
Es sind die Namen und Logos, die man in Luxuskaufhäusern erwartet. Und auch die Verkaufsfläche wirkt erstmal nicht ungewöhnlich. Nur der Blick auf die Preise deutet an, dass dies eine besondere Abteilung ist. Nur 200 Euro für einen Mantel, denn er ist gebraucht.
Ja, jetzt bin ich wieder gut.
Jetzt wird also gebrauchte Mode auch im Luxuskaufhaus verkauft. Secondhand, das ist auch für die junge Zielgruppe gedacht.
Paris ist bekannt für Mode und ich dachte, in die Galerie Lafayette muss man gehen. Und ich war überrascht, eine Secondhand-Abteilung zu sehen. Recyceln und wiederverkaufen. Große Kaufhäuser machen eine Philosophie daraus, um zu zeigen, dass sie verstanden haben und um den Anschluss an junge Kunden nicht zu verpassen. Secondhand ist eine einfache Art, verantwortungsbewusst zu konsumieren und die Preise machen sie leichter zugänglich. Und das spricht vor allem die junge Generation an.
Secondhand ist ein Riesentrend. Also das ist ja Kleiderkreisel, wirst du wahrscheinlich kennen. Kleiderkreisel ist ja eine Seite, die wurde ursprünglich ins Leben gerufen, also mit dem Gedanken, Kinderklamotten sind ja toll, aber die wachsen so schnell raus. Was macht man eigentlich dann damit? Und es ist irgendwie schade, wenn das alles weggeworfen wird und kann man das nicht noch ein bisschen zu Geld machen. Und dann hat man diese Kleiderkreisel-Idee entwickelt, und inzwischen ist das aber lang nicht nur für Kindermode üblich mit dem Secondhand, sondern es ist ein Riesenmarkt. Zalando bietet inzwischen Secondhand an, ganz viele High Fashion-Online-Shops bieten Secondhand an. Und ich habe es auch bei den Influencern immer häufiger an den Stories gesehen, dass sie auf Secondhand-Shops verweisen.
Die haben es quasi erzwungen, würde ich sagen. Denn die Influencer sind, wie soll man sagen, unverschämt frech in der Art und Weise, wie sie einfach in so Läden gehen, sich dort zehn tolle Kleider anprobieren, mitnehmen, dann ein Fotoshooting machen mit allen zehn Kleidern vor zehn verschiedenen Kulissen, damit sie für die nächsten zehn Tage Bilder haben und dann einen Tag später wieder zurückgehen und alles wieder zurückbringen. Und die Verkäufer im Grunde schon wissen, wenn hier wieder so ein junges Mädel zehn Kleider rausbringt, dann kriegen wir die hier morgen alle wieder. Dann wickeln wir jetzt ein Geschäft ab, dass wir morgen alles wieder zurück abwickeln müssen. Wir wissen nicht, in welchem Zustand die sind und so. Und dann sagt man lieber gleich, ey komm, dann machen wir hier mal Second Hand raus. Du kaufst die jetzt regulär und danach kaufen wir dir die wieder ab, begutachten die aber wieder. Es gibt da nicht einfach eins zu eins Geld zurück, sondern wir gucken dann erst mal, in welchem Zustand ist denn das so. Und das ist ein echtes Problem. Also hier, klar, Thomas Walde macht das so ein bisschen romantisch in seinem Tonfall, aber ich glaube, das ist hier eine ganz harte ökonomische Kalkulation, um sich da nicht weiter nur zum Opfer machen zu lassen.
Und das passt selbstverständlich gut in das Nachhaltigkeitsparadigma. Wir haben gehört, die Modeindustrie ist dafür viel Schlimmes, was den CO2-Ausstoß anbelangt, zuständig. Und wir hören noch mal rein, wie diese Zusammenarbeit funktioniert mit diesen Secondhand-Leuten.
Junge Menschen, die sonst vor allem Läden ansteuern, wie diesen im dritten Pariser Arrondissement. Clara Victoria kauft von Zwischenhändlern Secondhand-Mode und sucht auch selbst auf Trödlmärkten und Reisen, was sie finden und aufwerten kann. Angefangen hatte Clara als Influencerin. Heute beliefert sie mit ihrer Marke auch die Secondhand-Abteilungen der großen Kaufhäuser. Anfangs haben wir uns schon gefragt, ob sich eine solche Zusammenarbeit für uns lohnt, ob das zu unserer Marke passt. Dann haben wir uns gesagt, das ist eine Gelegenheit, eine Kundschaft zu erreichen, die bisher wenig mit Secondhand zu tun hatte.
Ich hoffe, das spielt sich gut ein, denn ich habe auch manchmal Gelegenheiten, wo ich denke, ich könnte jetzt mal einen coolen Anzug brauchen oder so, aber extra einen kaufen dafür? Nee, also wenn es die Gelegenheit gäbe, sich einen zu besorgen, von dem klar ist, der geht dann noch wieder zurück und es kostet nicht dreistellig oder so. Warum nicht? Also da ist noch viel zu holen.
Die Frage ist allerdings, ob sich dadurch tatsächlich jetzt umweltpolitisch etwas bessert. Natürlich kann man das jetzt bei dir in dem einen konkreten Fall sagen. Ja, du hättest dann nicht einen Anzug produzieren lassen, den du dann zu Hause hast im Schrank und nur einmal getragen. Aber was jedoch eher sich andeutet ist, dass es nochmal neue Kaufanreize gibt, also dass man jetzt sagt, dieses Stück ist jetzt nicht einfach gerade so gekauft irgendwo, sondern ich ergatter es. Ich beschäftige mich jetzt nochmal ganz anders mit dem Kauf und schicke natürlich, wenn es günstig ist, auch nochmal sehr viel mehr hin und her, was ja auch wieder CO2 problematisch ist. Also das ist wieder so eine Sache, dass man hier versucht, natürlich über eine andere Form des Konsums wieder, also den den den bösen Konsum abzulegen, aber indem man natürlich dadurch wieder so rebound Effekte eigentlich hat, dass dann wieder ganz viel gekauft werden kann und dass es zur Challenge wird, irgendwelche Mode zu kaufen, ist man sehr nahe wieder daran, dass das Kind genauso in den Brunnen fällt, wie anders auch.
Ja, die Gefahr besteht. Ich sehe es jetzt bei uns so, dass meine Frau organisiert das vor allem. Das sind auch, da braucht man gar keine großen Kleider, Kreisel oder so, sondern es sind manchmal nur so WhatsApp-Gruppen lokal, dass sich so 80 Mütter zusammenschließen und dann irgendwie Fotos von ihren Klamotten machen und fragen, wer braucht denn das, ist Größe so und so. Und dann findet sich schon wer. Und wir haben bei uns auch im Keller mehrere, und ich meine wirklich so im Dutzend mehrere, 30 Liter Kisten, diese transparenten, die es bei IKEA gibt. Deckel drauf, dann kann man die so stapeln, wo einfach nur Klamotten für Kinder in verschiedenen Größen drin sind, weil das so unglaublich lange durchrotiert. Und dann gibt es Winter und Sommer noch mal getrennt, werden ein paar in den Kofferraum, also ich organisiere da nicht mit, ich erlebe das dann immer nur, wie mal wieder zwei Kisten aus dem Kofferraum, in den Kofferraum, dann werden die irgendwo hingefahren, dann kommen die nächsten Kisten bei uns an, dann klingelt es irgendwie. Eltern, die ich kenne, sagen mir hier, das ist die Kiste und ich so, welche Kiste, ach so, hab der wieder hier und so. Und dann bringe ich die halt in den Keller, dann steht die da oben, dann holt sich meine Frau irgendwann hoch, macht sie auf, geht sie durch, stellt irgendwie fest, da sind jetzt doch zu viele Löcher drin, dann wird sowas aussortiert. Aber es ist eine unglaublich krass hohe Rotation an Kleidung für, sag mal mal, so U14-Kinder. Und ab 14 beginnen zumindest die Mädels, das untereinander einfach zu tauschen. Dann hat plötzlich die Tochter so eine Jacke an, die man gar nicht kannte vorher oder auch Schuhe oder so. Und dann weiß man schon wieder, okay, da wurde schon wieder durchrotiert. Dann scheint es aber irgendwo so einen Abriss zu geben. Und ich finde, das könnte man aber ein Leben lang so machen. Und das ist ja immer die Frage dann, wie kommt man aus der Gemeinschaft zur Gesellschaft? Also klar, und in Freundeskreisen kriegt man das einfach organisiert. Vor allem, wenn die Eltern aus reiner Notwendigkeit jetzt einfach mal ein Kind ausstatten müssen, das nun mal gerade 97 Zentimeter groß ist, aber das halt nur für ein Jahr. Ja, da gibt es einfach eine Notwendigkeit, diesen Moment dann auch wirklich mit viel Kleidung zu machen und zu wissen, der nächste Jahr kriegt ihr dann jemand anderes, dann kennt man auch irgendwen und dann geht das halt so durch die Familien. So, und das könnte man ja mit Hilfe des Geldes als Kommunikationsmedium wirklich mal für die gesamte Gesellschaft oder Stadtteile oder wie auch immer, da wo es sich lohnt, wo man auch, soll man jetzt vertrauen, dass man, wenn man Klamotten jetzt kauft, im Sinne von ist die richtige Größe, aber ist halt als Kilo-Ware verkauft, sollte man dann vertrauen, dass man nicht nur Müll bekommt. Und da wäre es halt, und das kann man ja lokal organisieren, sehr gut zu wissen, von wem hat man das eigentlich. Ach so, von Beate aus so und so, aus der Dings der Bums-Straße. Dass man da so ein Vertrauensnetzwerk irgendwie so hinbekommt und das Klamotten dann mehr rotieren, weil da könnte man sehr viel Druck aus diesem Salandu-Musten, neu verkaufen, verkaufen, verkaufen, verkaufen, dann scrollt man das durch und ist doch immer unzufrieden, sondern dass man da einfach so eine wirklich, dass man auch so ein Kleid, das man wirklich gerne getragen hat, einfach mal weggibt.
Lieblingsstücke habe ich ja keine, von daher hätte ich damit überhaupt kein Problem. Ich könnte da permanentere Rotation haben, würde mir überhaupt nichts ausmachen. Was allerdings ein großes Problem ist, ist, dass man Klamotten sehr schwer recyceln kann, vor allem diese Klamotten, die es heute so gibt. Das ist nämlich keineswegs so, dass das ja alles irgendwelche Baumwoll-Anzüge oder so sind, die ich sie gerne trage. Die bekommt man sehr gut recycelt natürlich, sondern inzwischen sind da so viele Substanzen drin, dass man sich fragt, was kann man denn eigentlich damit machen? Wir springen jetzt mal ein bisschen zu ZDF Zoom. Da geht es darum, dass H&M und Zara zwar keine Klamotten an-kaufen wie jetzt bei Breuninger, aber sie nehmen Recycling-Mode an.
Seit 2013 kann man bei H&M aussortierte Textilien in eine Altkleidertonne werfen. Zara, C&A und andere ziehen nach und stellen auch Container auf. Das Versprechen? Aus den alten Kleidern werden neue Textilien gemacht. Zwei Tüten pro Kunde und Tag nimmt H&M an. Dafür gibt es 15% Rabatt als Anreiz für den nächsten Einkauf. Die Aktion kommt an. Allein bei H&M wurden 2016 16.000 Tonnen Altkleider eingesammelt. 2019 waren es schon 29.000 Tonnen weltweit.
Zu Bord kommt jetzt ein Recycling-Experte, kein Nebel, der sagt, das Problem ist nur, Recycling ist mit dieser Mode kaum möglich.
Rund 70% aller neu produzierten Textilien bestehen aus synthetischen Fasern. Sie werden aus Rohöl gewonnen und sind schlecht wiederverwertbar.
Wenn ich da im Laden bin, wird ja schon ein Kreislauf suggeriert. Und ich denke, natürlich machen die aus meinen alten Klamotten irgendwas Schickes Neues.
Ja, das kann man rück so nennen, dass das eigentlich eine Vorspielung einer falschen Tatsache ist. Also wenn ich dann von Recycling spreche, auch wenn man dann später auf die Deklaration guckt, da ist ein Recycling-Einteil drin, wo der herkommt, ist gar nicht genau festgelegt. Und er kommt, sag ich mal, zu 99, 9 Prozent nicht aus Altkleidern. Kleidung zu Kleidung, Recycling findet so gut wie nicht statt.
Ja, also hier die Kreislaufwirtschaft zu etablieren, ist so wichtig. Diese Gesetze müssen so schnell jetzt mal kommen.
Ja, da könnte sich ja etwas tun. Im Zeitpodcast wurde das auch aufgegriffen. Da geht es um Fast Fashion, aus dem sich, aus der sich eigentlich nichts machen lässt.
Aber selbst, wenn es jetzt noch schlechter wäre, dann könnte man immer noch was daraus machen. Dann würde es gerissen werden zu kleineren Fasern und daraus noch Maler-Flies, Autodämmstoffe oder auch Putzlappen gemacht werden. Stefan folgt, hat sich das T-Shirt dann noch mal genauer angeschaut und hat auch mal aufs Etikett geguckt.
Made in China hat einen Elastik-Anteil, aber im Bereich Putzlappen würde das nicht in die ganz hohen Kategorien gehen. Es würde auf jeden Fall Geld kosten, um das zu verwerten.
Diese Stoffe, die für Fast Fashion verwendet werden, sind einfach extrem schlecht. Und die sind so schlecht, dass sie selbst den Textilrecyclern eigentlich kein Geld bringen, sondern eher Geld kosten. Und der Grund, warum sich das Geschäft für sie trotzdem lohnt, ist die sogenannte Kreme-Ware.
Ja, das ist dann die Ware, die wertvoller ist und aus der sich noch etwas machen lässt. Wenn man jetzt über Fast Fashion spricht, dann denkt man jetzt gern so an Primark oder H&M. Und ich glaube aber, dass man sich ein bisschen da eigentlich was vortäuscht. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es so ist, dass wir es nur mit Billigmode zu tun haben, die so schlecht ist, sondern ich glaube auch, so ist zumindest mein Eindruck, dass sich die hochpreisige Mode, und mit hochpreisig meine ich wirklich auch 1000 Euro für ein T-Shirt, dass sich diese Mode auch extrem verschlechtert hat. Also wenn ich dann mal bei Breuninger bin und mir diese Trendmode ansehe, wenn ich mir diese Sneaker, die Schlappen und all das ansehe, was da für immenses Geld verkauft wird, dann habe ich da keine gute Qualität in der Hand. Das sind einfach industriegefertigte, ganz billige Stoffe, die aber das entsprechende Logo haben und die die entsprechende Story haben. Ich will jetzt diese ganzen komischen Marken, die es da gibt, die im Trend sind, die man dann für 800, 1.500 Euro kaufen kann, nicht nennen, aber es ist definitiv so, dass es da überhaupt nicht um in irgendeiner Weise Qualität geht. Da ist auch ja nicht mehr ein handwerkliches Geschick oder so dabei, sondern es sind einfach 0815 Stoffe, die aber das entsprechende Logo haben und ich glaube, die sorgen auch ganz erheblich für diese Fast Fashion Stoffe, für diese Fast Fashion Dilemma, dass man eigentlich damit nichts mehr anfangen kann, außer es zu verbrennen. Also das ist also nicht, weil man kann da leicht, man kann da so leicht klassistisch argumentieren, dann sagt man ja ja genau, die kaufen ja alle bei Primark oder so. Und das ist aber keineswegs der Fall. Also es ist definitiv so, dass die Qualität bei diesen ganz vielen hochpreisigen Dingen einfach nicht gegeben ist, weil man da auch sehen kann, wenn man sich mal ansieht, was wird da verarbeitet, dann ist da selten noch mal eine richtige Baumwolle oder so dabei. Da ist irgendwas zusammengerührt und es geht aber auch nicht darum, jetzt ein Teil zu schaffen, ein T-Shirt, das 1000 Euro kostet und 10 Jahre hält, sondern es geht einfach nur darum, dass das jetzt gerade der Trend ist für diesen Sommer. Und deswegen sollte man dieses T-Shirt kaufen und das wird ganz beschleunigt, auch extrem beschleunigt durch Influencer, durch Rapper, durch Instagram vor allem, die dann solche Hypes auslösen auf irgendwelche Produkte und deswegen ist das Augenwischerei so zu tun, als sei das jetzt einfach nur Fast Fashion, also das, was billig ist. Ganz zum Schluss würde ich noch gerne zwei…
Wir können ja hier kurz festhalten, für Fashion, Mode, Klamotten allgemein gilt, Wachstum ist gesteigerter Verbrauch.
Ja, ganz genau.
Ja, Wachstum ist gesteigerter Verbrauch. Wenn das dazu geschnitten hätte auf dieses Thema, dann hätte er recht.
Wachstum ist gesteigerter Verbrauch. So und jetzt, das ist genau das richtige Stichwort, das du nennst, denn wir hören jetzt noch zwei Clips aus der aktuellen Levi's Werbung. Wir kennen die Jeans, wir kennen die Mode, die Shirts auch, wo es nochmal groß drauf steht. Und jetzt hat sich Levi's gesagt, wir müssen auch mal irgendwas zum Klima sagen. Und dann sah ich im Kino diesen Werbespot.
We can change that.
So, also hier sehen wir also ein Werbespot einer Mode Marke und die prangert an, dass immer mehr gekauft wird. Und da müssen wir jetzt mal für eine Veränderung sorgen. Und jetzt habe ich das ein bisschen zusammengerafft. Der Spot dauert zwei Minuten, aber ich habe es auf 20 Sekunden zusammengerafft. Was da jetzt für eine Argumentationsfolge, die tatsächlich sehr Harald Wälzer mäßig ist. So was heißt denn das jetzt eigentlich will jetzt Levi's auf Profit verzichten? Also dann machen die halt 50 Prozent Umsatz weniger, weil die Leute einfach nichts neues kaufen. Das kann es nicht sein. Also ich glaube es den natürlich in keinem Moment, sondern man weiß, es gibt dieses Thema, das ist virulent. Man muss sich irgendwie jetzt dazu verhalten. Gerade Corona hat es nochmal hervorgebracht. Also was versucht man jetzt? Man stellt sich als die Guten da. Wir haben uns da mal Gedanken darüber gemacht und besser wäre ja, wenn die Leute nicht so viel kaufen. Aber was man natürlich möchte, ist, dass man alle Leute, also das ist Betriebswirtschaft, also Betriebswirtschaft ist. Ich lot sie jetzt alle zu uns Guten rüber. Die sollen hier ihr Geld ausgeben. Aber es wäre natürlich ein Fiasco für Levi's, wenn die Leute auf so einer Ebene denken würden und sagen, genau, und früher habe ich ja immer von den vier Jeanshosen im Jahr gekauft und jetzt kaufe ich nur noch zwei. Dann hätten die ein erhebliches Problem. Und volkswirtschaftlich gesehen wäre das auch ein erhebliches Problem, wenn die Leute jetzt plötzlich sagen, wir kaufen alle nur noch halb so viel.
Trotzdem steckt da ja das Eigeständnis drin. Wir kriegen es qualitativ nicht gebacken, also müssen wir quantitativ ran. Viel ist viel zu viel und weniger ist mehr besser.
Ja, und sie werben natürlich hier für eine besondere Qualität, sodass es dann lange hält. Dabei ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass die meiste Mode nicht entsorgt wird, weil sie entsorgt werden muss, weil sie nicht mehr hält, sondern man macht das eigentlich, weil man irgendwas Neues haben möchte.
Wobei man ja sagen muss, das Ziel eines Hosenherstellers ist ja auch nicht, dir zwei Hosen für je 100 Euro zu verkaufen, sondern die eine Hose für 250 Euro zu verkaufen. Also mehr Umsatz bei weniger Material.
Das kann natürlich jetzt die Entwicklung bei Livers sein. Das muss man mal schauen, ob die einfach jetzt ins hochpreisige mehr gehen und sagen, aber davon brauchst du dann auch nicht so viel. Insofern haben die da dann Doppelprofit gemacht. Aber es ist schon sehr eigenartig, dass wir jetzt in einer Zeit leben, wo die Konzerne, die damit Geld verdienen, dass viel verbraucht wird, dazu aufrufen, nicht so viel zu verbrauchen. Karl Lagerfeld wurde ja auch immer auf diese Fast-Fashion-Geschichte angesprochen, ob er sich dann da nicht schuldig fühle oder so, oder ob die Konzerne da nicht jetzt umdenken sollen. Und dann sagt er, ja, dann haben die halt halb so viel Umsatz, können sie ja machen. Aber er hätte noch kein Konzern getroffen, der jetzt gerne halb so viel Umsatz machen möchte. Und da hat er natürlich erst mal recht. Also das ist die Logik des Kapitalismus. Und deswegen sehr fraglich, was von solchen Botschaften da zu halten ist. Ich glaube, es ist ein ganz guter Marketing-Coup und könnte lieber mehr Kunden zuspülen, als man sie bislang hatte.
Ja, wir können ja sagen, es ist unglaublich viel Nichtwissen oder direkte Verlogenheit oder Verblendung in diesem System. So grundsätzlich. Das sehen wir bei den einzelnen Marken, bei den Händlern, bei der ganzen Idee, die jetzt kommt, sollten wir nicht alles ins Internet verlagern. Wird es dann besser? Wird es dann nicht besser? Ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, wie viel Papier, wie viel Verpackung wir brauchen und so, das ist so unglaublich, dass Bücher nicht mehr gedruckt werden können, weil wir einfach Material brauchen zum Verpacken. Und ich hatte da vorhin schon diesen einen Clip angemerkt. Haar II der Tag hat ja über die Innenstädte auch mal berichtet, die machen ja immer so Föhtonartige eine Stunde Radio dazu. Und dabei wurden diese 50 Sekunden hier gesendet. Ich würde mal sagen, das ist das Segment. Wir machen noch mal kurz was Akademisches. Nach dieser ganzen Gefühlichkeit zum Thema, das tolle Shopping-Erlebnis, die Innenstadt, unsere Lebenswelt und so weiter werden wir noch mal akademisch. Und dabei haben sie diese 50 Sekunden hier gesendet.
71 Prozent sagen, die Innenstadt ist für mich ideal, weil ich hier mir die Produkte richtig anschauen kann und sie gleich mitnehmen kann.
Anschauen, anfassen, beraten lassen, im Idealfall bestaunen. Auch Eva Stüber vom Institut für Handelsforschung sieht hier große Chancen.
Das ist etwas, was der stationäre Handel sehr gut ausleben kann, dass man eben persönlich zusammenkommt in einem Raum, dass man diesen Community-Gedanken vielleicht stärker spielt, dass man auch dieses Produkt erleben in andere Dimensionen bringt, dass man sie vielleicht auch anwendet, dass man gemeinsam bastelt, lernt, schraubt und kreativ ist. Das heißt, ein ganz neues Geschäftsfeld, was vorher im Handel ja so gar nicht bedient wurde, wo es eher nur um den Produktverkauf ging.
Ja, ich stelle mir das so ein bisschen vor. Man hat selber so einen großen Einkaufsladen, möchte immer noch gut vermieten. Also lässt man sich irgendwelche Studien schreiben, in denen steht, der Kunde will noch mal basteln, schrauben und kreativ sein, das gemeinsam erleben und da, wo er wohnt. Und dann kommt so ein Bild, warum währenddessen in der Realität die Leute doch alle zu Hause sitzen und schnell das bestellen, was sie brauchen. Wir binden jetzt einfach dieses ganze Thema mal zusammen. Also sowohl Fashion im Grunde so Luxuskonsum, den man sich so gibt, wenn man alt und grau ist und das weiße T-Shirt nicht mal reicht, wie auch immer. Da kann man sich ja überlegen, welches Budget brauche ich denn jetzt? Oder andere Seite des Spektrums, Lebensmittel sind zum Überleben da, die muss man auf jeden Fall kaufen. Egal, in welchem finanziellen Zustand man ist. Und dazu noch, egal, ob man es alleine lebt oder gemeinsam, in der Stadt oder auf dem Land, wir brauchen, wir konsumieren, sagen wir es mal so. Und jetzt haben wir ja vorhin schon den großen Strukturwandel, die Innenstadt. Menschen gehen weniger ins Büro, es wird weniger geschäftig. Es ist sehr viel verlagert sich nach Hause. Wo ist dieses Zuhause? Naja, jedenfalls nicht mitten in der Innenstadt. Also macht das immer aufwendig, dahin zu fahren. Hier mal diese kleine Zahl aus dieser Art, die ich vorhin schon genannt habe, aber die als so kognitiver Anker für dieses Thema, was ich jetzt kurz durchsprechen möchte, doch ganz wichtig ist.
In den Vereinigten Staaten beträgt der Wert des Lebensmittelsektors 900 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr.
900 Milliarden pro Jahr. Also jedes Jahr.
Das ist so viel, wie der BDI für die nächsten zehn Jahre zur großen Transformation haben möchte.
Ja, und das ist nur der Umsatz einfach, der da stattfindet. Ja, ein iPhone kostet 1000 Euro, aber eine fünfköpfige Familie braucht jeden Monat ein iPhone zum Überleben und das lässt sie an dem lokalen Supermarkt. Also sie haben so viel Geld und es geht um so viel Geld, dass wir es uns kaum vorstellen können. Es stellt alles in den Schatten und es verändert sich radikal, denn das letzte, wo wir noch wirklich vor Ort einkaufen, ist der Einzelhandel. Alles andere ist alternativ auch schon ins Internet abgewandelt. Einzelhandel immer noch nicht so richtig. Und jetzt beginnt dieser Krieg um diese 900 Milliarden. In Amerika leben 300 Millionen Menschen, in Europa 500 Millionen. Wir gucken also nach Europa, wo es mehr als eine Billion Euro pro Jahr sind, um die jetzt einfach richtig hart gekämpft wird. Und wie hart. Ich war wirklich überrascht. Ich habe diese Artedoku, die wurde mir so empfohlen, vom YouTube-Algorithmus. Ich habe sie auch gesehen. Ja, da habe ich so geguckt und habe gedacht, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Da habe ich es auf Twitter geschrieben und dann haben so ein paar Leute auch reagiert. Ich dachte, das ist ja wirklich unglaublich und so. Arte hat also eine Doku, die heißt Auslaufmodell Supermarkt und da geht es gleich am Anfang, ersten vier Sekunden, setzen gleich den Ton.
In großen Supermärkten geht es schlecht. Ein ganzer Sektor schwächelt.
So, ein ganzer Sektor schwächelt. Das sind die großen Supermärkte. Wir alle wissen, was ein Supermarkt ist. Es ist sozusagen richtig fest drin. In jedem Film kommt, wenn man ihn braucht, ein Supermarkt vor, um irgendwie das Lokale zu zeigen oder wie auch immer. Nur die Geschichte des Supermarktes ist gar nicht so alt. Und das fand ich super interessant, wie sehr sich das doppelt. Es sind die 60er. Also mit der Erfindung der Containerschifffahrt, auch erst in den 60ern, kam auch der Supermarkt.
1963 revolutioniert die französische Carrefour-Gruppe den Lebensmittelhandel. Mit der Gründung des ersten Übermarché. Ein großflächiges Selbstbedienungswarenhaus auf der grünen Wiese.
Ja, wir haben es also wie mit der Buchdruckerei, 500 Jahre Modernität, einfach nur, weil man nicht mehr alles spontan im Gespräch geregelt hat, aber trotzdem nicht irgendwie der Normalfall, also sich da nicht täuschen lassen, dass man glaubt, der Buchdruck ist der Normalfall. Nee, das war eigentlich die kleine, wie heißt dieses schöne Wort? Nee, dieses Wort für eine Phase, also nicht die Zäsur der Bruch, sondern diese Phase. Ich hab's in Redaktionsschluss für die Gutenberg-Galaxie, also 500 Jahre Gutenberg-Galaxie. Wir hatten vorher das spontane Gespräch auf dem Feld und jetzt haben wir es mit Social Media wieder. Und wir lassen eigentlich diese 500 Jahre Buchdruck fast so ein bisschen hinter uns. Erleben wir ja auch bei der Frage, wen wählen wir eigentlich? Na ja, Trump natürlich, der Typ, der ja am lautesten rumbrüllt und so. Und alle anderen Errungenschaften der Moderne lassen wir so hinten runterfallen. Und so ist das auch ein bisschen mit dem Supermarkt. Supermärkte gibt es seit den 60er-Jahren, also jetzt 40, 50, 60 Jahre. Das ist so der Zeitraum. Wir können also nicht einfach sagen, der Supermarkt ist ja normal, der bleibt für immer. Das ist eine Erfindung für die Ewigkeit. Das hat man beim Fernseher auch gedacht. Das hat man an alle Smartphones und keiner hat mehr einen richtigen Fernseher zu Hause. Da nutzt man ihn nicht so wie die Sozialität dahinter mit Sendeanstalten und so weiter, das eigentlich gedacht war. Sondern es ist nur noch so ein Abspielgerät. Also das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig zu verstehen, dass nur weil wir uns alle daran gewöhnt haben, es nicht heißt, dass nicht Amazon in fünf Jahren alles übernehmen kann komplett und uns einfach einen Lebenswandel zeigt, der uns dann so wirklich mal in die Zukunft katapultiert.
Und der Einkauf dann völlig anders aussieht. Ich erinnere mich immer noch an ein Gespräch mit einem Kollegen damals bei der Zeitung. Der meinte zu mir, dass er Supermärkte auch toll findet und all das. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber es ist ja eigentlich immer lästig. Also man geht ja nicht in den Supermarkt dem Sinne gern, sondern man braucht halt Dinge und macht diesen Einkauf. Und dann meinte er, nein, das ist ja doch nach der Arbeit so schön entspannt, wenn man dann noch in den Supermarkt fährt und da so durchfährt. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, aber du verabsolutierst jetzt da dein persönliches Empfinden. Ich sitze halt lieber zu Hause und gucke einen Film und schiebe nicht gern Einkaufswagen durch die Gänge.
Also sehr viele Leute steigen in ihr Auto nach der Arbeit und fahren dann gerne nach Hause und nicht noch mal erzwungenermaßen in den Supermarkt. So, aber Supermärkte sind da und bislang alternativlos. Jetzt allerdings beginnt der Kampf.
Die großen Lebensmittelkonzerne versuchen ihre Schäfchen ins Trockene zu bringen. Denn die Konkurrenz steht schon in den Startlöchern.
So, und dann zeigen sie uns hier einen Amazon-Fresh-Laden. Das ist ja dann nach Whole Foods, die sie aufgekauft haben, ihre wirklich eigene Kreation. Hier ein bisschen wirtschaftswissenschaftlicher Zeitgeist mit Philipp Moatit.
Heute möchten wir es klein und überschaubar. Hypermärkte stehen für die Entmenschlichung des Handels und übermäßigen Konsum in einer Zeit, in der das ökologische Bewusstsein wächst und die Auswirkungen unseres Konsums sichtbar werden.
So, der große Supermarkt, der uns unseren Konsum vor Augen führt. Das ist natürlich interessant, fand ich irgendwie. Ja, wir gehen heute in den Supermarkt und sehen dort diese ganzen Sachen. Und stellen dann irgendwie fest, das ist aber ganz schön viel. Ist das denn gut für die Umwelt? Also der Supermarkt verleitet uns heute schon, ein schlechtes Gewissen zu haben, wenn wir da einfach eine Tonne Fleisch in der Auslage sehen und denken, nee, ich will ja eigentlich gar kein Fleisch mehr essen. Jetzt kriege ich aber hier plötzlich das Fleisch meiner ganzen Nachbarschaft vorgeführt. Leben wir eigentlich richtig, wie wir leben? Und das ist super interessant, weil da steckt natürlich das Potenzial drin für Amazon, uns das einfach alles zu verstecken. Amazon zeigt mir ja nur meinen Bedarf an und nicht sozusagen die Umweltzerstörung von allem. Amazon versiegelt keine hunderte Quadratmeter, damit ich da mein Auto abstellen kann, während ich einkaufen gehe und so. Also es besteht die große Möglichkeit, unglaublich raffinierte Strategien der Vertuschung jetzt noch mal neu zu entwickeln. Die Supermärkte geben sich sehr viel Mühe, es irgendwie so angenehm wie möglich zu machen. Man kommt rein und steht erst mal voll im Obst und Gemüse und so. Ist natürlich dann für den einen oder anderen, wie du es eben geschildert hast, so ein tolles Erlebnis, wo sieht man noch mal so hell beleuchtete Natur im Grunde. Dann soll man da auch nur reinbeißen. Nur das Beste aus der Natur, nicht den ganzen Baum, nur die Frucht und so kriegt man da serviert.
Es riecht gut, es ist eine angenehme Atmosphäre, all das. Aber man sieht natürlich die Arbeit. Das ist hier ganz schön schon angedeutet. Also nicht nur die Überfülle sieht man, die einen überlegen lässt, ist das alles so richtig. Eben habe ich da noch was vom Klimareport gehört. Wir sehen auch Leute, die arbeiten. Und das ist etwas, was mitunter auch einen irritieren kann. Was ich damit meine, ist ja, man ertappt sich ja selbst dabei. Man bestellt was, bekommt es geliefert und nimmt das so entgegen, sagt vielen Dank und will aber eigentlich sofort vergessen, dass jetzt da ein Mensch bei Eiseskälte und Nieselregen aus dem Auto gestiegen ist, gehofft hat, dass er mich auch antrifft. Ich habe noch ein bisschen länger gebraucht, bis ich von oben kam, mache dann die Tür auf, sage ja danke und tschüss. Und man will sofort vergessen, dass der sehr wenig Geld verdient, jetzt bekommt er ein bisschen mehr Mindestlohn, aber das ist auch nicht der Rede wert, dann am Ende für ein Altersauskommen und so weiter. Das will man also wieder verdrängen. Und ähnlich sehe ich natürlich auch, wenn ich mich so noch durch den Supermarkt begebe, Menschen, die da arbeiten und kann dann mal so hochrechnen, wie sieht dieser Arbeitsalltag aus? Wann begann er? Wie wird wohl die Entlohnung sein? Und wenn ich das jetzt so verdrängt bekomme oder übertüncht bekomme, dadurch, dass man sagt, hier sind einfach die Produkte, die du brauchst, das kann so einfach sein, dann ist das sehr reizvoll.
Ja, wie viele Leute kennen das Gefühl, dass man aus Mitleid doch auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt was kaufen möchte, weil sich da jemand die Finger abfriert, um irgendwelche Holzschnitzereien von seinem Opa zu verkaufen? Und das kriegt man natürlich super ausgeblendet, wenn man unter der Kontrolle des eigenen Fingers nur das angezeigt bekommt, durch Scrollereihe und Suchbegriffe eingeben, was man wirklich will. Und der ganze Rest wird einfach ausgeblendet. Also hier sind doch noch einige Möglichkeiten, sich zu positionieren. Und noch gehen wir in die Supermärkte. Und ich habe es dann selber erst hier in dieser Art der Doku richtig verstanden, wo das Problem ist. Wie stirbt eigentlich ein Supermarkt oder so eine Einkaufsstraße? Oder wie auch immer, aber bleiben wir mal so konkret beim Supermarkt. Wenn er dann wirklich weg ist, also wenn wirklich so ein Ausverkauf stattfindet, dann kriegt man mit, ah, die haben schon fünf Jahre gelitten. Weil die tun natürlich alles dafür, es dir zu verheimlichen, dass es denen schlecht geht, weil du dann wenigstens noch kommst und nicht denkst, jetzt irgendwie und so. Die wollen ja gute Laune verbreiten. Nur so Supermärkte sterben ja trotzdem und auch jetzt schon. Und das sieht man hier ganz deutlich, wenn man sich die Produktkategorien, die im Supermarkt zu angeboten werden, mal anschaut.
Seit etwa 15 Jahren stellen wir in den Hypermärkten einen kontinuierlichen Rückgang beim Verkauf der Non-Food-Produkte fest. Doch das ist der Bereich, der die größten Margen bringt, vor allem im Textilbereich.
So, der Non-Food-Anteil. Wir haben natürlich jetzt das Phänomen, oder sagen wir mal vor einem Jahr, es gab diesen großen Lockdown. Sehr viele Geschäfte hatten zu, Supermärkte hatten aber weiter offen und die haben dann den Non-Food-Bereich der Geschäfte, die zu waren, einfach übernommen. Also es gab dann plötzlich bei Lidl und bei Rewe so aller möglicher Kram, den man so fürs Leben braucht, den man ansonsten nicht bei Lidl oder Rewe findet oder bei EDEKA, sondern eben in den dafür vorgesehenen Läden. Dann sind die natürlich bei diesem Geschäftsmodell geblieben, weil die Leute gelernt haben einfach, ich kann meine Schraubenzieher auch bei Rewe schnell kaufen, muss ich gar nicht in den Spezialladen gehen. Und genau dieses Phänomen des Kannibalismus, den gibt es auch online. Der Supermarkt funktioniert überhaupt nur mit diesen geringen Maschen auf Nahrungsmittel, also Milch für 69 Cent und so weiter, wenn sehr viele Leute bereit sind, die höhermaschigen Sachen, 20 Prozent Masche auf dem Schraubenzieher mitzumachen dort.
Beziehungsweise bei Klamotten sind das ja auch 40 Prozent oder mehr.
Eine Lampe, Hausschuhe und so weiter.
Genau, da kann richtig gespart werden, aber durch Online-Shopping ist natürlich auch die Frage, wieso soll ich jetzt da diese Hose in der Metro kaufen, wenn ich die auch woanders bekomme oder bei EDEKA. Das ist also der entscheidende Punkt, der sicherlich, also viele Leute haben ja Klamotten, glaube ich, in Supermärkten gekauft, weil es so schön praktisch war. Also das war ja jetzt nicht, man wollte kein Einkaufserlebnis. Also wenn man sich jetzt für Mode interessiert und möchte ein Mode-Einkaufserlebnis haben, dann macht man das nicht im Supermarkt. Aber wenn man jetzt eher so wie du eingestellt sind, sagt man, ach das ist praktisch, die Hosen passen immer, die T-Shirts sind gut, dann hat man gesagt, ja dann nehme ich die dann immer mit, wenn ich da meinen Einkauf mache. Wenn ich das aber jetzt im Internet genauso praktisch tun kann, fällt das weg.
Genau, dann fällt das weg. Und es ist seit 15 Jahren ein Supermarktsterben in Europa und in Amerika zu sehen, einfach nur dadurch, dass immer mehr Nonfood aus den Regalen dort verschwindet und damit die Gesamtmarge der Supermärkte immer weiter schrumpft. Und diese Kalkulation dahinter, da fragt sich ja immer Amazon, warum gibt es das eigentlich für denselben Preis wie im Laden, obwohl die doch und so weiter. Und dann macht man sich gar keine Vorstellung, wie sind die Margenkalkulationen für stationäre Läden eigentlich. Und hier kriegen wir es mal dargebucht.
Die Betriebskosten der Supermärkte sind sehr hoch. Um diese Kosten decken zu können, braucht der Inhaber eine Mindestgewinnmarge von 20 Prozent. Liegt er darüber, macht er Gewinn. Liegt er darunter, Verlust.
So eine Gewinnmarge von 20 Prozent heißt auf das ganze Supermarktsortiment, das umgesetzt wird. Und so ein deutscher Durchschnitts-Supermarkt macht irgendwie so 25.000 Euro Umsatz am Tag. Da kann man sich ja dann überlegen, wie viel Geld ist das denn, 20 Prozent davon. Aha, so und so viel. Da kommen also alles rein, was Betrieb der Städte, also, dass es da warm ist, dass es da hell ist, dass da jemand arbeitet, Lohnkosten und so weiter, da kommt alles rein. Und dann liegt man so bei 20 Prozent. Und jetzt hat sich Amazon nicht gesagt, wir nehmen das ganze Sortiment, sondern wir nehmen erst mal das mit den hohen Margen. Also wir nehmen uns genau den Teil, der auch vorteilhaft für uns ist, weil den müssen wir nicht kühlen, den müssen wir nicht zeitnah zustellen, der kann durchaus n Nacht irgendwo auf dem Parkplatz rumstehen oder so. Dann liefern wir die zu. Also Amazon hat sich da einen unglaublichen Vorteil erschlichen, indem sie einfach sozusagen eine Win-Win-Situation hatten. Die Sachen, die sie sowieso gut online handeln lassen, hatten auch noch durch Zufall eine besonders gute Marge und haben die Supermärkte die letzten 15 Jahre eigentlich so richtig ausgetrocknet. So, warum gibt es noch Supermärkte? Weil die Supermärkte diesen Druck, den sie da erleben, bei ihrem Essensteil, also bei dem, das sie eigentlich brauchen, Nahrungsmittelversorgung, weil sie den Druck einfach weitergegeben haben und das ist ganz erstaunlich, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Um beste Konditionen zu erhalten, erfolgen die Einkäufe der 5.300 Geschäfte der Garfur-Gruppe über eine zentrale Beschaffungsstelle. Alle europäischen Konzerne verfügen heute über eine solche Zentrale.
Vor wenigen Jahrzehnten hatte ein Lieferant hunderte, zum Teil tausende Ansprechpartner im europäischen Handel, die letzten Endes beim Eingekauft haben. Heute sind vermutlich mehr als 80 Prozent des Volumens abgedeckt nach der Verhandlung mit 20 Personen.
Er hat jetzt gesagt, 20 Personen. Den ganzen, oder sagen wir mal 80 Prozent, wie er sagte, also den ganzen, grob geholfen. Der ganze Einkauf für europäische Supermärkte organisieren gerade 20 Leute. Da sitzen also, nehmen wir mal einen davon, geht in so ein Büro, trifft dort ein Hersteller, also Nestle oder so, eigentlich ein ziemlich großes Unternehmen, und sagt denen einfach, ja, also wir können deine Milch in unseren Rewe, Edeka, Lidl, Aldi, also einfach überall, nur noch für den und den Preis verkaufen. Bist du damit einverstanden? Nein? Dann fliegt das alles raus. Dann nehmen wir nämlich den anderen Lieferanten. Und dann fliegen Molkereien, die eigentlich 17 Milliarden Umsatz oder so machen im Jahr, einfach aus allen Sortimenten gleichzeitig raus, von heute auf morgen.
Und wie finden diese Verhandlungen statt? Das wird ja da auch gesagt. Hochinteressant.
Also da hab ich einen Klick.
In kleinsten Büros sitzt man dann dort. Es kann sein, dass die Heizung so aufgetreten ist, dass man einen Schweißausbruch bekommt. Es kann auch sein, dass es eiskalt ist, dass sie die Fenster aufgemacht haben. Also es hat ein bisschen was von Foltergefängnis und dann Verhör. Und dann schafft man solche Atmosphäre. Da wird dann im Kleinen aufs Schärfste aufgehandelt, wie viel Cent was kosten darf. Und für kleinere Händler, die dann noch in irgendeiner Weise an diesen Gesprächen teilnehmen müssen, also es gibt ja vielleicht auch spezialisiertere Dinge, wo das dann noch nicht unter so einem Mantel ist, kann das bedeuten? Also es ist der absolute Wahnsinn, dass man dann sagt, ja, du bekommst den Preis dann weiterhin, aber dafür musst du morgens in den Supermarkt und deine Waren dort selbst einräumen. Also ich habe das gesehen und dachte, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Und da ist dann jemand, der um 6 Uhr früh in den Supermarkt geht, eigentlich Lieferant ist, aber dann selbst dort die Ware einräumen muss, weil das quasi zum Vertrag mit dazu gehört. Sonst könnte er gar nicht mehr davor kommen. Also deswegen, wir haben ja Amazon hier von Anfang an immer kritisiert und tun das auch zurecht, denke ich. Aber man sollte in keiner Weise romantisieren, wie momentan die Industrie aufgebaut ist. Also das ist keineswegs angenehmer. Also da kann man auch mit Jeff Bezos, glaube ich, aushandeln, was man bekommen möchte. Das hier ist keineswegs angenehmer oder besser.
Genau. Jeff Bezos ist einfach nur noch eine kleine Spur härter, als die auch schon hart sind. Und das heißt, die sind schon ziemlich hart.
Ja, also das bedeutet auch, dass die Einzel-Supermarkt-Franchisen nehmen, also die dann einen kleinen Markt haben. Die bekommen schlechtere Einkaufskonditionen als die, die den größeren Markt haben. Also die kaufen aber alle dann bei Kaffur oder was auch immer. Das bedeutet, also einer sitzt dann da und sagt, ja, theoretisch könnte ich es billiger einkaufen als Ware, wenn ich einfach zu dem größeren Supermarkt, hier dieser Kette, deren Teil ich bin, fahre und dort den Einkauf mache, was aber verboten ist. Denn ich muss die Preise akzeptieren, die der Konzern hier will. Und das hat wiederum zufolge, dass ich so wenig Gewinn mache, dass ich der einzige und noch einer bin, die überhaupt hier fest sind und die anderen laufen nur über Mini-Jobs. Also auch da müsste man mal fragen, wie dieses Mini-Job-System natürlich da auch gute Dienste leistet für diese Konzerninteressen. Und dann wird dann der Leiter eines kleineren Supermarktes genannt, was der verdient. Ich glaube, das war dann irgendwas von...
Ja, da kommen wir gleich noch zu. Die zahlen alle hier parat. Also dieses Modell des großen Einkaufes. Wir haben die Supermärkte, die sich zusammenschließen, auch über die einzelnen Ketten hinaus. Und dann einen Vertreter haben, der für sie gesammelt einkauft, in den von dir geschilderten Situation, also kleiner Raum, vier Quadratmeter, ein Tisch, zwei Stühle, da eine Stuhl wackelt. Man beschimpft die Leute, die da kommen, lässt die erst mal vier Stunden warten. Es ist zu kalt, macht irgendwelche sexistischen Witze und sagt ihnen dann, wir kaufen jetzt das, was ihr herstellt, für genau diesen Preis. Seid ihr einverstanden? Dann sagen die nein, dann sagt man okay, dann fliegt das alles raus. Dann sagen sie, okay, wir sind doch einverstanden. Also die eine ist dann auch einfach aufgestanden, ist gegangen, dann wurde sie für einen eigenen Leuten angerufen, geh wieder hin, stimm allem zu, was du da hast, ansonsten fliegen wir nämlich aus allen Sortimenten raus. Plus ungefähr 5 Milliarden Euro der Einnahmen der Supermarktketten bestehen auch darin, dass man, und das ist echte Erpressung, die da stattfindet, dass man den Lieferanten einfach sagt, wir können das nur zu dem und dem Preis verkaufen und ihr müsst noch zusätzlich alle eure Mitarbeiter einmal im Jahr zu unserer Fortbildung schicken, die kostet pro Nase 20.000 Euro. Bitte dann und dann überweisen. Also solche Sachen finden da statt. So was fand also statt in dem Markt, der sich auf der einen Seite, also der Verkäuferseite, der Supermarktkettenseite, komplett konsolidiert und monopolisiert hat. Das hat natürlich zur Gegenbewegung geführt. Die Lieferanten und Hersteller und Produzenten haben das dann auch gemacht. Wir hören hier einen französischen Abgeordneten, der die Dynamik mal beschreibt, denn darauf mussten natürlich die Händler auch wieder reagieren.
Nicht nur die großen Handelsketten sind gewachsen, sondern auch die Lieferanten. Sie sind genauso mächtig geworden wie die Ketten selbst, einige sogar noch mächtiger. Deshalb schlossen sich die französischen Supermarktketten mit anderen Ketten in Deutschland, Spanien, Italien und anderen europäischen Ländern zusammen, um den Lieferanten weiterhin überlegen zu sein und bei diesen weiterhin günstige Bedingungen durchsetzen zu können.
Wir haben also Ketten, die sich national organisieren, Einkaufsgemeinschaften bilden, dann Lieferanten, die darauf reagieren und sagen, du kannst nicht beim Konkurrenten eine Molkerei kaufen, sondern wir haben uns mit denen geeinigt. Wir wollen hier ein bisschen mickdiktieren, die Preise. Also man trifft sich sozusagen eins zu eins, woraufhin die Endler dann sagen, ja dann schließen wir halt die Superketten europaweit zusammen. Was bedeutet, in ganz Europa gibt es derzeit nur noch vier Organisationen, die überhaupt Einkauf organisieren.
Die Verhandlungen finden nicht mehr auf Länderebene, sondern auf europäischer Ebene statt. Die europäischen Ketten haben ihre Kräfte gebündelt und vier große internationale Einkaufsgemeinschaften gebildet. Copernic mit der französischen Gruppe Leclerc, der deutschen Rewe Group und weiteren Partnern mit über 12.500 Geschäften in ganz Europa. CWT zu der unter anderem Garfour und Cora gehören. Diese Allianz vertritt die Interessen von 16.000 Geschäften. Argecour mit sechs Handelskäpten, darunter die französische Gruppe Entermarché und Edeka Deutschland. Diese Gemeinschaft vereint 24.000 Geschäfte. Und schließlich Horizon International mit 15.000 Märkten.
Die haben den Markt unter sich aufgeteilt.
Ja, keine von den vier hat weniger als 10.000 Supermärkte. Manche sogar 24.000.
Darüber sprechen wir nie. Das ist das Interessante, wenn du in FDP und CDU-Kreise gehst, man hat sich darauf eingeschaltet, die Konzerne aus dem Silicon Valley müssen wir mal.
Aber hier wird so etwas nie thematisiert. Ja, die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung wurde verhandelt. Man hat immer auf Google und Amazon weitergeguckt, dass die deutschen Versicherer bei Datenverarbeitung da kunden. Alles kein Thema. Hier auch. Wir haben hier Supermärkte, da ist der einzelne Händler, gerade bei EDEKA, da steht immer der Name drüber, wer betreibt den eigentlich? Der hat mit nichts zu tun. Der kriegt halt das Angebot, dieser Lkw kommt am Montag und macht dein Regal voll, dann sagt er ja, dann kommt er halt und macht dein Regal voll. Du musst dann leben mit den Marschen, die da kommen. Also da gibt es einfach vier Organisationen, wenn Nestle oder Danone oder Mars, oder wer auch immer jetzt einen Termin hat, was weiß ich, 1.600 Sachen sollen in Europa verkauft werden. Wir haben eine neue tolle, also Haribo oder so, hat eine neue tolle Gummibärchenpackung, möchte ich anplatzieren. Dann sagen die vier, ja, unsere Bedingungen, um das in 14.000 Supermärkten vorrätig zu haben für die Kunden, sind diese, ja oder nein? Da gibt es keine Verhandlung. Und entsprechend greift hier auch dieser französische Abgeordnete einmal die Situation auf. Wir unterstellen ja immer Amazon. Es ist total intransparent. Wir sehen ja gar nicht, was die mit den Algorithmen machen, was sie nutzen, ihre eigenen Plattformen aus, ihre eigenen Profite usw. Ja, so ist das halt hier auch. Wir haben es mit komplett intransparent.
Niemand weiß, was da vor sich geht, was verkauft wird und zu welchem Preis. Niemand weiß, was mit dem Geld passiert. Es gibt keinerlei Kontrollmöglichkeiten.
Ja, wir wissen gar nichts. Und Amazon kann hier nichts schlimmer machen. Denn Amazon würde das nur ersetzen und für uns Kunden ein bisschen besser machen. Da würde er nicht mehr zum Supermarkt gehen, sondern das wäre der Anspruch, den Amazon dann bietet, es dir zu bringen einfach. Aber Amazon würde hier kein gutes System ablösen durch was Blödes oder so, sondern hier haben wir es einfach mit einer schon katastrophalen Lage zu tun.
Ganz genau. Und man kann dieses System übrigens hacken, und zwar über TikTok. Das ist ganz erstaunlich, denn natürlich kann man jetzt nicht ein Produkt rausbringen und sagen, lieber Rewe, stell das doch mal ins Regal. Man hat keine Chance. Man sieht jetzt ja gerade, wie der Markt aufgeteilt ist und was man dann alles dafür tun müsste. Aber was man sehen kann, ist, dass es ja so einige Trendfood-Hersteller gibt. Also beispielsweise gibt es so einen Kuchenteig, den man naschen kann. Also den man nicht dann verarbeitet zu einem Kuchen, sondern man kann den einfach so naschen. Ich weiß nicht, wie das Produkt genau heißt. Jedenfalls hat man dieses Produkt entwickelt und lanciert über TikTokker. Hat das also verschickt, hat Influencer-Marketing betrieben und und und. Was zur Folge hatte, dass die jungen Leute das sahen, in den Supermarkt gingen und danach fragten, bis dann irgendwann Rewe-Chefs und so weiter diesen Hersteller anschrieben bzw. anriefen und sagten, was ist denn das da überhaupt und wir haben das ja gar nicht. Wie kann das sein? Und dadurch ist es dann den Supermarkt gewandert. Die Lebensmittelbranche ist ja eine, wo man dann doch auch noch mit anderen Margen rechnen kann, wenn der entsprechende Name drauf steht. Weshalb ja sehr viele Hip-Hop-Influencer gerade eigene Lebensmittel auf den Markt bringen, Pizza, Eistee und so weiter. Und solche Hypes auslösen. Und da kommt dann auch der Weg oft von den sozialen Medien hin zum Supermarkt. Da scheinen die irgendwie über den direkteren Weg dann dorthin zu gelangen.
Genau, mit solchen Ideen lässt sich natürlich spielen. Die Frage ist tatsächlich, in einem Supermarkt neben einer Schule, würde der noch funktionieren, wenn es da keine Milchschokolade, keine Dings, Kartoffelchips, also Pringles zum Beispiel und keine Coca-Cola gäbe? Also nichts von Cola, keine Fanta, keine Cola, nichts. Würde der Supermarkt immer noch genauso gut funktionieren? Nö, das würden die Schüler sehr schnell feststellen und denen dann einfach meiden. Nur, würden sie es wirklich, und wie kaufrelevant sind denn die Jugendlichen, die so markenspezifisch sind, sind nicht doch die älteren Käufer, die dann so in Familien einkaufen, aufs Geld gucken usw. relevanter? Das wurde 2018 hier in einem Megakonflikt ausgefochten, als nämlich wirklich mal Nestle-Sachen bei Agilcor verschwanden aus den Regalen.
2018 lehnt der Schweizer Konzern Nestle die Bedingungen von Agilcor ab. Die Strafmaßnahmen kommen schnell und koordiniert. Einige Nestle-Produkte verschwinden aus den Regalen mehrerer Mitglieder der Händlergemeinschaft.
Für Nestle muss es überraschend gewesen sein, denn bis dahin hat es sowas noch nicht gegeben. So eine große Auslistung von Produkten von einem so großen Konzern. Es sind quasi über Nacht 163 Produkte in mehreren tausend Verkaufsstätten verschwunden. Und zwar nicht nur in einem Land, sondern in Europa verteilt.
Nestle hat ab diesem Moment die Dinge nicht mehr verkauft und hat dann auch schnell einen Rückzieher gemacht. Nestle hat eigentlich verloren. Wir sagen immer, Nestle sind die Bösen, das sind die Großen. Selbst Nestle ist diesen Kartellen da eigentlich komplett ausgeliefert. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, was passiert, wenn jetzt wirklich Amazon kommt, von denen wir wissen, wir haben ja die amerikanischen Anhörungen gehört, die verschwenden auch einfach mal pro Monat 400 Millionen, um das Windelgeschäft zu sich zu holen. Also Amazon hat da Spielräume, Sachen auch auszusitzen und saß eigentlich bisher immer am längeren Hebel. Und jetzt ist die Frage, haben es die Händler übertrieben? Also diejenigen, die für die Supermärkte einkaufen, dann wird es in die Supermärkte geliefert. Irgendwann, ganz am Ende, die letzte Meile, kommt ja der Kunde ins Geschäft und möchte was kaufen, möchte sich versorgen. So und da hören wir mal als letzten Clip die Kalkulation des Händlers vor Ort. Also der für die ganzen Mega-Milliarden, wenn nicht Billionen Euro dieses Geschäft aufrecht erhält. Am Ende ist es der Käufer vor Ort, der tatsächlich auf den Kunden trifft. Und der hat derzeit folgende Gewinnmarge.
Carrefour setzt aktuell verstärkt auf die Mini-Märkte in den Stadtzentren.
Wie sieht es mit den Zahlen aus?
Die sind das ewige Problem. Die Zahlen sind nicht schlecht, aber die Gewinnmarge stimmt nicht. Auf 2, 2 Millionen Umsatz haben wir 17.000 Euro gemacht.
17.000 Euro?
Rotor.
Auf 2, 2 Millionen.
Ja, 17.000 Euro auf 2, 2 Millionen Umsatz. Das ist sehr wenig, aber wir müssen ja weitermachen.
Also wenn für den Händler die Gewinnmarge bei einem halben Prozent oder so ist, und wir gesehen haben, im System selbst werden aber 20 Prozent Gewinnmarge gerechnet, nur die fallen nicht bei ihm an. Der tatsächlich Kontakt zum Kunden hat, sondern die bleiben irgendwo in dieser Wertschöpfungskette. Und jetzt sagt Amazon, wir machen einfach Dispersion. Wir kommen einfach hin und sagen, die 20 Prozent verringern wir dadurch, dass wir gar keinen Supermarkt betreiben, sondern einfach nur ein zentrales Lager. Die Leute, die fahren ja eh schon rum. Je nachdem, wie man bestellt, kommt ja dreimal am Tag ein Amazon-Mann zu einem. Es ist ja nicht so, dass der einmal am Tag kommt, dann hat man ihn verpasst, sondern hier in so dicht besiedelten Gegenden sind die ja quasi ständig in der Tour. Und wie lange kann man auf den Supermarkt Einkäufe warten? Naja, man klickt halt die ganze Woche was zusammen und möchte es dann am Samstag geliefert haben. Also das ist, glaube ich, keine große Herausforderung für Amazon, das einfach zu übernehmen. Und wahrscheinlich haben sich die Supermarktketten hier in eine Position gebracht, die geradezu einladend ist für Amazon, das von heute auf morgen zu übernehmen. Also nicht die nächsten zehn Jahre oder so, sondern das eine anfängt, sich das zu bestellen. Und dann fahren hier nur noch kleine LKWs durch die Straßen, die einfach rechts und links die Sachen verteilen, die halt vorher zusammengeklickt wurden.
Es gibt ja schon diese Shopping-Apps, die ja viel genutzt werden, Flink und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, wie die alle heißen. Mit denen kann man ja schon so einen Blitzeinkauf sich organisieren. Also man klickt das an, was man braucht. Das ist aber dann auch noch sehr beschränkt. Also unendlich groß sind die Lager nicht. Und dann bekommt man das innerhalb von 30 Minuten oder 20 Minuten nach Hause gebracht, wo ich dann auch immer sage, das ist ja furchtbar. Also diese Art der Arbeit, die daraus dann auch entsteht. Also Leute, die dann durch die Gegend hetzen und irgendwie versuchen dann, dir möglichst schnell das Zeug zu bringen. Also ich würde sagen, da wäre dann über so eine Amazon-Struktur vermutlich das sogar noch würdiger zu lösen, als das jetzt gerade der Fall ist. Und ich glaube aber auch, dass Amazon bereits eine gute Infrastruktur hat, um da ganz viel zu machen. Und die müssten jetzt das nur so einsetzen. In der Dokumentation geht es ja noch darum, dass Amazon einige Filialen ja jetzt selbst betreibt. Also Supermärkte, so ganz spezielle. Aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht der Weg, dass jetzt Amazon hier in Zukunft 2.000, 3.000 Filialen aufbauen wird als moderne Supermärkte. Höchstens mal so zum Vorführen, was wir alles da können, mit der Digitalisierung im Einkaufswagen. Aber ich glaube, der Weg ist tatsächlich, dass man solche Dinge möglichst schnell bringt. Und ich frage mich, ob man da vielleicht auch noch den einen oder anderen Aufkauf erleben wird. Also Amazon könnte ja auch sagen, die kaufen jetzt solche Leute wie Flink oder so auf. Aber vielleicht müssen sie es auch gar nicht. Vielleicht können sie so raumverdrängend sein, dass sie einfach die anderen dann kaputt machen, diese entsprechenden Lieferdienste jetzt, die ein bisschen boomen, mit denen sich an der Börse mal schnell Geld verdienen lässt. Und dann hört man nichts mehr davon.
Das ist so meine Vermutung. Da hänge ich auch sehr diesem Scott Galloway zur Dispersion. Wir haben es hier schon besprochen, dass man Wertschöpfungsketten einfach überspringt. Sehr viele Posten. Wenn man sich jetzt solche Lieferketten wie von Rewe kauft, hat man die halt auch an der Backe. Da hat man Personal, das muss man erst mal umlernen, um da irgendwas anders zu machen. Wenn man neu aufbaut, und wir haben ja gesehen, dass Amazon einfach auch mal 100.000 Leute in einem halben Jahr einstellen kann und dass dann trotzdem alles funktioniert. Ich glaube, die große Gefahr ist ja wirklich, dass Amazon mit einer eigenen Infrastruktur, die für die Konkurrenten wieder so intransparent ist, dass sie gar nicht verstehen, wo die Gewinne herkommen. Denn die Kalkulation ist ja einfach nur, wie auch schon bei den Non-Food-Sachen, nur mit einer etwas kleineren Marge. 20% des Verkaufspreises kann Amazon benutzen, um die Logistik zu organisieren. Und das ist eine Herausforderung, würde ich sagen, die nimmt Amazon sportlich. Denn die 20% kriegen die auf jeden Fall organisiert. Ein Supermarkt ist so teuer, der fliegt schon mal raus. Diese ganze Kühlung vor Ort, dieses ganze Werben usw. Und die Supermärkte, die Amazon selbst betreibt, die laufen ja nur unter Marktforschungs-Gesichtspunkten. Die wollen ja einfach nur sehen, wie kaufen Leute ein. So wie Google immer sehen wollte, wie lesen Leute Bücher, Zeitungsartikel usw. Deswegen dieses ganze Google News Zeug. Und es gab ja schon mal den Vorschlag von Amazon, der hat auch damals bei der FAZ so ein bisschen für Unruhe gesorgt. Jedenfalls wollte man das ganz eifrig kommentieren. Dass Amazon nämlich gesagt hat, wir sehen voraus, was Leute bestimmen. Und dann halten wir das schon mal vor. Und wenn dann der Klick kommt, dann liefern wir. Und damit war ja nur gemeint, dass man die großen Logistikzentren, also diese Fulfillment-Center, wo einfach alle Artikel, die zur Verfügung stehen, da sind, mehrere Millionen, dass man das noch mal direkt vor den Toren der Stadt, wo es wirklich nur noch eine Stunde Fahrt ist, um 100 Leute zu erreichen, dass man da in kleineren Einheiten, weil auch Mietpreise höher sind und so weiter, schon mal vorsortiert, was sehr wahrscheinlich bestellt wird. Und das kann man ja bei Lebensmitteln auf jeden Fall sagen. Ich sage jetzt mal aus meiner Familie heraus, die Erfahrung, wir kaufen im Grunde jede Woche zu 80 Prozent dasselbe. Also das ist nicht sehr kompliziert, herauszufinden, was wir wohl am Samstag bei Aldi kaufen werden. So, ja, und das kann man uns wirklich mal vorpacken, dass wir dann den letzten 20 Prozent auch irgendwie spontanmäßig hier und rechts und da mal ins Regal greifen. Ja gut, aber das kriegt man auch organisiert irgendwie. In der Hinsicht wundert mich eigentlich, dass Amazon den großen Sprung noch nicht gemacht hat. Aber ich würde sagen, er steht eher morgen als übermorgen bevor, dass wir hier wirklich zumindest in den Großstädten eine Liefersituation bekommen, bei der man sich wirklich drauf verlassen kann, dass das dann auch funktioniert. Wenn einfach ein Lieferfenster ist, Samstagmorgen 8 bis 11 Uhr, dass dann dein Wochenendeinkauf wirklich bei dir auf der Türschwelle steht. Das geklingelt wird, weil klar ist, samstags sind die Leute eh zu Hause und es ist auch zu erwarten gewesen, dass das geliefert wird. Und dann fährt er direkt weiter zur nächsten Adresse und das Ratsip hat sie ausgeliefert bekommen. Und wir kriegen dann kein schlechteres System als das, was wir damit vernichten. Denn diese Einzelhandelorganisation, die ist echt nicht gut. Also das ist einfach ein ganz grausames Business, was hier stattfindet. Tja, was soll man sagen?
Wir machen eine Pause.
Ja, wir machen hier eine kleine Pause. Wir sagen sie für alle, aber ihr kriegt sie gleich nicht mit, denn es geht jetzt direkt weiter für euch. So, Wolfgang, die Pause ist vorbei. Slow Fashion hast du uns angepriesen. Ich habe gesagt, man kann ja durchaus mal eine Fanta im Supermarkt kaufen. Wie bezahlen wir das alles?
Natürlich alles mit dem Bitcoin. Zumindest ist das möglich in El Salvador. Und ich habe mir gedacht, wir gucken ja gerne mal aufs globale, was ist in China los und sonst wer, aber wir schauen uns mal ein kleines Land an. Ein Land, an das ja ein bisschen mehr als 6 Millionen Einwohner hat, volkswirtschaftlich nicht bedeutsam ist. Es gibt sehr viel Kriminalität, sehr viel Korruption. Aber sie haben einen neuen Präsidenten ja seit einer Weile in El Salvador. Das ist Nayib Bukele und der ist so ganz anders. Und wir hören jetzt mal so zur Einführung einen Beitrag von Markus Plate aus dem Deutschlandfunk.
Mit markigen Worten hatte El Salvadors Präsident Nayib Bukele nach seiner Wahl 2019 der Bandenkriminalität den Kampf angesagt. Zum Beleg wurden Bandenmitglieder in Gefängnissen auf engstem Raum zusammengefärcht vorgeführt. Und die offiziellen Mordraten sind seit 2019 um gut 40 Prozent zurückgegangen. Wir haben uns entschieden, über das gesamte Land Quarantäne zu verhängen. Auch mit Beginn der Pandemie reagierte Bukele schnell und entschlossen. Es gab Geld für die Ärmsten und per Dekret wurden alle Rechnungen gestundet. Wer den strikten Lockdown nicht beachtete, dem drohten Zwangsinternierungen. Die im lateinamerikanischen Vergleich niedrigen Infektions- und Sterberaten während der ersten Welle ließen Bukeles Zustimmungswerte weiter steigen. Auch dass mittlerweile zwei Drittel der Salvadorianer geimpft sind, stärkt Bukeles Image des Machers und Kümmerers.
Klingt ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Also jemand, der durchgreift, der allerdings auch mit Mitteln durchgreift, die er dann so am Parlament vorbeischleust und dass er dann da auch Leuten mit Internierungslager droht. Das ist etwas, was jetzt liberal-demokratisch nicht so vereinbar ist. Aber es ist also ein Macher. So inszeniert er sich und das tut er vor allem auch über die sozialen Medien.
Der gerade 40-jährige Bukele weiß seine Erfolge zu kommunizieren. Mittels einer Hundertschaft junger YouTuber und Influencer nutzt Bukele die sozialen Medien, Facebook, Twitter, TikTok, aber auch die öffentlichen Fernsehkanäle für das Gespräch mit der Bevölkerung.
Und mit einer Hundertschaft ist so eine Art Presse-Dienst gemeint, weil sonst hält man sich ja immer so ein Dunstkreis, bei dem unklar ist, wie die Beziehungen so sind.
Aber er ist einfach mit dieser Community wohl sehr stark vernetzt, sodass er einfach mit denen laufend kommuniziert, in Streams auftaucht, bei Twitter sehr aktiv ist. Also wir haben ja jetzt wieder mit einem Twitter-Präsidenten zu tun. Wir haben über Trump ja unendlich viel gesprochen. Wir haben Modi auch schon mal als den Vorgänger von Trump quasi gezeigt, der mit den sozialen Medien so umging. Und Bukele ist jetzt der, der da eigentlich in die Fußstapfen tritt, allerdings noch engeren Draht zu der Community pflegt und auch versucht, deren Lifestyle zu kopieren, versucht, deren Sprache zu sprechen. Ein bisschen wie die junge FDP das hier tut, aber doch in sehr größerem Ausmaße und mit größerem Erfolg. Er ist sicherlich ein populistischer Anführer, so kann man ihn bezeichnen. Und da ist es natürlich auch nicht unüblich, dass man es mit der Gewaltenteilung nicht ganz so genau nimmt.
Mit Erfolg. Seit den Parlamentswahlen im Mai dieses Jahres weist Bukele fast eine Zweidrittelmehrheit hinter sich. Wenig später setzt er den Oberstaatsanwalt und oberste Richter ab. Sie seien Teil des alten korrupten Systems. Saeira Navas, Anwältin und ehemalige Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der nationalen Zivilpolizei, sieht diese Eingriffe mit großer Sorge. Mit dem Bukele treuen neuen Oberstaatsanwalt wird es schwierig, Korruptionsfälle der Regierung von Nayib Bukele zu untersuchen. Und mit der Absetzung der obersten Richter ist die Gewaltenteilung nicht mehr gewährleistet. Ich befürchte einen Missbrauch der Justiz für die strafrechtliche Verfolgung von politischen Gegnern, so wie wir das in der letzten Zeit schon gesehen haben. Wie zum Beleg dafür erlässt das von Bukeles Partei dominierte Parlament Ende September ein Gesetz, das ein Drittel aller Richterinnen und Richter des Landes verrentet.
Manchmal höre ich das und denke mir immer noch so ganz neu, warum machen die das immer? Das ist doch bescheuert. Klar, die Gründe kennt man irgendwie, aber.
Naja, aber das ist also eine generelle Tendenz, das haben wir ja in Polen überall sehen können. Und hier selbstverständlich auch, wenn gleich das noch nicht so weit gediehen ist, wie in anderen Ländern, ist da schon Vorsicht angesagt. Und er ist da doch zu vielem fähig, gerade weil er so locker flockig auftritt und man erst mal nicht den Eindruck hat, ach ja, wir haben es hier mit so einem rechten Populisten oder so zu tun. Zumal er sich auch, was gesellschaftliche Fragen anbelangt, dann auch sehr offen wiederum zeigt, dass er ist nicht in irgendeiner Weise fundamentalistisch da aufgetreten. Aber wir sehen jetzt hier schon so ein Prinzip, also man konzentriert die Macht sehr auf sich. Das bedeutet im Übrigen auch, dass Bukele natürlich das jetzt anstrebt, dass er unendlich lange Präsident werden kann, denn das ist eigentlich nicht vorgesehen. Aber wir wissen, das ist ja dann sehr schnell auszuhebeln, dass man doch auf Ewigkeit der Präsident bleiben kann. Das kennen wir aus anderen Ländern. Das will er sich so ein bisschen abschauen. Das ist ja auch was Trump immer mal sagte. Ja, der Xi macht das doch eigentlich toll. Das müsste man hier auch eigentlich mal einführen. Nun, da gibt es ja dann noch die Presse, die dem im Wege sein könnte. Auch dazu was im Deutschlandfunk.
Das ist Naib Bukele, ein staatlicher Propaganda-Apparat und immer heftigere Angriffe auf die unabhängige Presse. Ich fürchte, es könnten Medien geschlossen werden. Schon jetzt stehen Polizei und Militär nachts stundenlang vor den Häusern von Kolleginnen. Diese Woche hat Bukele im Parlament ein Gesetz über ausländische Agenten eingebracht. Auch hier befürchtet die Anwältin Zaira Navas, dass damit regierungskritische NGOs kriminalisiert werden könnten, die oft über internationale Entwicklungsgelder co-finanziert werden.
Also passt echt in so ein globales Bild irgendwie. Man hört das so und denkt sich, ja, kenn ich.
Ja, und was dann da genauso reinpasst, ist man muss irgendwie eine andere Geschichte erzählen. Man muss sich jetzt irgendwas ausdenken als Unix Selling Point, was einen so besonders macht. Also das ist natürlich bei Modi dieser Hindu-Nationalismus, dass er das verbindet mit dem Yoga-Tag und, und, und. Und Bukele, modern, 40 Jahre alt, hat sich gedacht, diese Krypto-Leute, diese Kryptomanie, das ist doch eigentlich was, was wir hier etablieren könnten. Da könnten wir doch vorangehen. Und wir hatten im Salon schon mal kurz drüber gesprochen. Im September wurde dann der Bitcoin eingeführt als Währung.
Mitten während der Kontroversen kündigt Bukele dann die Einführung des Bitcoins als offizielles Zahlungsmittel an. Seit Anfang September kann in El Salvador nun theoretisch mit der Kryptowährung bezahlt werden. Ein reines Ablenkungsmanöver, meint Angelica Carcamo, Präsidentin der salvadoranischen Journalistenvereinigung APES. Bukele muss ständig etwas haben, um Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen und von anderem abzulenken. Er lässt das Bitcoin-Gesetz in zwei Tagen ohne öffentliche Diskussion durchs Parlament peitschen. Die Menschen verstehen nicht, was das bedeutet, haben ja oft kein Bankkonto, kein Internet oder Handy. Aber die Gesellschaft ist erst einmal beschäftigt.
Ja, das ist nur eine Spekulation von mir. Aber Bitcoin, da hängt man sich als Thema auch gerne dran, wenn man einfach das Milieu, das gerade online am meisten für Furore sorgt und auch das größte Engagement irgendwie zeigt. Wenn man das auf seine Seite holen will, dann macht man irgendwas mit Bitcoin.
Und dieses Milieu ist recht groß und wir werden jetzt wirklich sehr verrückte Dinge hören. Ganz kurz, als das eingeführt wurde, gab es auch schon Proteste gleich dagegen, denn El Salvador ist ja ein sehr armes Land. Also das ist ja etwas, was man sich erstmal vergegenwärtigen muss. Es wird da jetzt der Bitcoin eingeführt in einem Land, in dem vier von 20 Einwohnern in Armut leben. Die Hälfte der Kinder und der Erwachsenen des Landes, die leben von weniger als 1, 25 Dollar am Tag. Und in diesem Land führt man jetzt den Bitcoin an. Da kann man ja schon fragen, wer profitiert denn davon? Vermutlich ja nicht die Armen, wenn gleich das nahegelegt wird. Denn die wurden dann auch mit so einem kleinen Begrüßungsgeld ausgestattet, wo sich auch schon die Frage stellt, wie sollen die das jetzt so ausgeben? Aber dazu kommen wir gleich. Es gab jedenfalls Proteste. Der Handelsblatt Podcast hat darüber berichtet.
Wir fordern die sofortige Wiederherstellung der verfassungsmäßigen Ordnung. Wir sind mit der Wiederwahl des Präsidenten nicht einverstanden. Wir fordern, dass das Bitcoin-Gesetz aufgehoben wird. Es war ein Gesetz, zu dem die Öffentlichkeit nicht befragt wurde. Es nützt nur denen, die Geld haben, den Betrügern, die Geld waschen.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Das war im September. Jetzt sind wir im November. Und da hat sich Großes angekündigt in El Salvador. Es gab so ein Bitcoin-Krypto-Event. Sowas, wie man das so kennt aus der Szene, irgendwie Bühne, Lautmusik, DJs, irgendwelche verrückten Animationen und und und. Und wer tritt da auf? Na, Bukele. Und er tritt auch so auf, wie man ihn jetzt immer häufiger sieht, nämlich nicht mit Sacko und Hemd oder so, sondern mit einer umgedrehten weißen Baseballkappe und dann so einem Bermuda-Outfit. Steht er dann da, wie so ein Bitcoin-Dude halt aussieht, also wie man sich ihn vorstellt, so sieht dann auch Bukele aus und tritt folgendermaßen als Präsident eines Landes auf die Bühne. Ich empfehle das auch mal, wir hören jetzt da Ausschnitt, aber man muss da einmal so reinschalten, weil man nicht glaubt, was man da sieht. Also dagegen ist ein Donald Trump hoch seriös und wirklich staatsmännisch.
Ich wollte gerade eben schon sagen, bist du sicher, dass du nicht irgendwelche Drehbücher uns hier gerade vorstellst, dass das wirklich die Realität ist?
Ja, Bitcoin Event, Bukele tritt dort auf. Aber da er ja der Präsident ist, muss er auch das Protokoll beachten und muss jetzt einzelne Regierungsmitglieder begrüßen.
Hier ist der Vizepräsident, da drüben.
Es ist total absurd und diese johlende Masse dann davor und alles, was ich über Kryptowährung denke, bestätigt sich dann in einem solch 30-minütigen Clip nochmal. Das ist ein Event gewesen, bei dem ganz viele Influencer da waren, irgendwelche Twitch-Streamer, also alles, was so auf dieser Kryptowelle reitert, sieht jetzt in El Salvador das neue Mecker, wo man überall hin muss, um jetzt Gelder zu machen. Als der Bitcoin gelauncht wurde, als offizielle Währung im September, war auch ein altbekannter da, Logan Paul, der ist natürlich auch gleich dahin gereist und hat sich da ablichten lassen auf irgendeiner großen Poolparty. Es ist vollkommen absurd und jetzt ist also dieser Bitcoin eingeführt, aber jetzt muss ja der nächste Schritt kommen und jetzt versucht Bukele sich einmal so eine gewisse geschichtliche Tradition zu stellen. Gehen wir doch mal zurück zu Alexandria.
Wenn Alexander der Größte das Weltkönig war, erstaunten sie diese Alexandrassen.
Aber sie erstaunten 20 Alexandrassen über den Allgemeinen.
Und die Idee war, diese Alexandrassen nicht um die Territory zu schützen, die sehr groß war und die Alexandrassen sehr klein waren, sondern die Idee hinterher war, dass diese Alexandrassen die Becken des Hoffnisses für den Rest der Welt sind.
Natürlich, Alexander der Grüne ist tot, und der Emperor ist getötet, und du weißt, das Rest der Geschichte.
Aber das war die Idee. Okay, es ist Realität, aber der Typ lebt gerade seine eigene Fan-Fiction, glaube ich.
Ja, er hat dann auch gleich eine Animation parat. Im Zentrum dieser Bitcoin City steht ein Vulkan, also über Geothermalwärme will man dann Energie gewinnen, einmal um die Stadt mit Energie zu versorgen, aber vor allem um Bitcoin Mining zu gewährleisten. Und darum gruppiert herum ist dann eine hochmoderne, technologisch aufgerüstete Stadt. Und überall kann man mit Bitcoin bezahlen. Es wird also ganz großartig sein.
Ich finde, wenn er statt Bitcoin sich um das Thema Cannabis bemüht hätte, würde das alles besser passen, so insgesamt, wenn wir ihm zuhörten.
Ja, es ist ganz erstaunlich. Also das Einzige, was es geben soll, ist eine 10%-prozentige Mehrwertsteuer. 5% davon gehen dann in die öffentliche Versorgung und ich glaube, 5% dann auch wieder fürs Bitcoinen drauf. Und der Rest ist also steuerfrei, egal, womit man sein Geld verdient. Man wird keine Steuern zahlen müssen. Das ist das große Versprechen, das dann alle anlocken soll. Und erhofft sich dann da einen großen Kapitalzuwachs, weil die Leute aus dem Ausland alle dorthin strömen. Denn sie müssen ja nur diese 10% Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen. Und es ist natürlich auch ein Irrglaube zu denken, dass man daraus alles finanzieren kann. Nur geht es ja auch nicht nur darum, dass man diese Steuern hat, sondern man will, dass die Leute jetzt in diese Bitcoin City investieren und hat so einen Bitcoin-Bond, den man aufsetzen möchte. Und es ist ja so, dass man in Bitcoin zum Teil sehr schwierig investieren kann. Und jetzt glaubt man also, mit so einem Bitcoin-Bond sei das alles sehr viel leichter. Wir hören jetzt mal Samson Mao, der ist dann auch aufgetreten. Der ist der Geschäftsführer oder CSO von Blockstream. Das ist auch so eine, ja, was ist denn das eigentlich? Das ist so ein Unternehmen, das mit Bitcoin und mit Kryptowährungen Geld verdient. In der Form, dass die auch zum Teil Satelliten haben, die dafür sorgen, dass das Mining weitergehen kann, wenn man Stromausfall ist und so weiter. Also auch dick im Bitcoin-Geschäft drin. Und der tritt nun auch auf die Bühne und erklärt ein bisschen dieses Geschäftsmodell.
Es ist die Singapur von Lateinamerika. Und wenn die USA weiter steigt, dann alle Norden und Südamerika. Aber das ist ein großer Schritt. Also sehe ich kein Problem, eine Billion Dollar Bonds zu füllen. Es gibt eine 5-jährige Lockup auf dem Bonds. Also das ist eine halbe Billion Dollar Bitcoin, die 5 Jahre auf dem Markt ausgerichtet sind. Wenn du noch neun Bonds füllen, das sind zehn Bonds, dann sind 5 Billionen in Bitcoin für 10 Jahre auf dem Markt ausgerichtet.
Ja, überzeugt dich das, dass die Leute jetzt in diese Bonds investieren. Und die Idee ist natürlich auch, dass das ja immer wertvoller wird, weil der Bitcoin ja auch immer wertvoller wird. Und er glaubt dann auch, dass so ein FOMO-Hype entstehen wird, also Fear of Missing Out. Man ist jetzt Vorreiter in El Salvador und viele weitere werden folgen. Und man hat jetzt diesen unglaublichen Vorsprung sich aber schon erarbeitet.
Also das mit den Bonds ist ja ein bisschen so. In den Tagesthemen wurde am 20. und die versuchen ja immer eine Erklärung zu geben, warum ist jetzt was an der Börse passiert. Der Bitcoin ist teurer geworden als 66.000 Dollar. Warum? Weil er jetzt auch verbrieft vorliegt, also in so einer Art Bond. Man kann jetzt Futures auf dem Bitcoin handeln. Und da hat sich der Podcast Fiat Money, links da oben, ich suche es nochmal raus, wie die heißen. Die haben sich da auch Gedanken drüber gemacht und meinten dann, ne, das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, den Bitcoin zu verbriefen, denn der Bitcoin ist ja, wenn man ihn braucht, da. Man kann ja etwas mit ihm tun. Er liegt ja in der Wallet vor. Man kann ihn benutzen, während man, während Future-Geschäfte ja eigentlich gemacht werden, um Preise auch dann zu stabilisieren. Wenn man nicht genau weiß, wie das Wetter wird, von dem die Ernte abhängt, man verkauft einfach schon mal den Ertrag des Feldes. Je nachdem, ob der dann oberhalb oder unterhalb des vorher ausgehandelten Preises liegt, auf lange Sicht, die 20 Jahre, wird sich ja wohl irgendwie einpendeln. Also, dass man solche Schwankungen da irgendwie einrenkt und einschränkt und für alle Marktteilnehmern erträglich macht. Aber das ergibt beim Bitcoin überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Vielleicht finde ich den Clip gleich noch mal, den habe ich mir auch rausgeholt. Und wenn ich solche Ideen höre, wie wir machen da einen Bond draus und so, gerade beim Bitcoin, und das ist ja dem Milieu und der Community total wichtig, ist es ja entscheidend, den auch wirklich zu haben. Und nicht nur ihn verbrieft, ein Versprechen darauf. Denn dann kann ich ja auch Fiatmoney nehmen.
Wir kommen dazu gleich, das ist ja gut, dass du es ansprichst, aber hier nochmal auf diese FOMO Idee.
Also die Spieltheorie an diesen Bitcoin-Bonds ist einfach verrückt. Das ist der Anfang der Nation-State-Bitcoin-FOMO.
Ja, es ist absolut verrückt, dass man jetzt glaubt, alle anderen Länder werden eigentlich auch auf diesen Zug aufspringen wollen. Und worum es hier eigentlich geht ist, man hat ein Investor-Projekt. Na ja, gut, es gibt noch viele populistische Führer, die jetzt vielleicht da gerade hinschauen und sagen, ja, das könnte man auch machen. Aber natürlich treibt man den Bitcoin immer weiter in die Höhe. Also der ist halt knapp. Und wenn man solche Hypes produziert, dann steigt der Bitcoin im Wert. Aber daran zeigt sich ja immer deutlicher, dass es nichts mit Geld zu tun hat, der Bitcoin. Denn Bitcoin lebt ja gerade jetzt dieser Hype davon, dass er volatil ist, während jedes stabile Geld davon lebt, dass es nicht volatil ist.
Genau, deswegen kann man auch sagen, man hat es gar nicht mit einem Geld, sondern mit einem Gut zu tun, dessen Wert halt einfach steigt. Man braucht doch das im Geld, um das zu kaufen. Und nur weil Menschen bereit sind, dafür Dollar zu geben, gewinnt der Bitcoin Geld, so wie jedes Gut, das einen Wert gewinnt. Nun hat er ja von FOMO gesprochen, also Fear of Missing Out, Angst, etwas zu verpassen. Wenn stimmt, was er hier vermutet, dass nämlich FOMO alleine den Preis und die Entwicklung des Bitcoins dahin bringt, dass dann irgendwann mal das Szenario dieses, alle Länder beteiligen sich mit Bronze usw. machen das dann irgendwie, dann müsste er ja eigentlich eingestehen, dass die bisherige Erfolgsgeschichte von Bitcoin, auch nur auf FOMO basiert. Also dass der ganze Wert des heutigen Bitcoins nur darin besteht, dass immer mehr Menschen dachten, oh Scheiße, ich verpasse hier was, ich mache auch mal mit. Das wäre natürlich eine ziemliche Bankrotterklärung für den Bitcoin, denn wenn FOMO ihn generiert, den Wert, dann ist es auch alles ehrlich gesagt nichts wert.
Genau, aber das ist generell eigentlich so, also Geld hat ja, oder es gibt nichts mit einem intrinsischen Wert. Also Gold hat keinen intrinsischen Wert. Nun kann man sagen, Gold kann man für manches nutzen. Gold schmückt einen und und und, aber an sich hat Gold keinen Wert. Wenn man jetzt einfach Gold verbieten würde und sagen würde, ab sofort kein Gold mehr, Gold darf nicht mehr getragen werden, was auch immer, dann würde Gold sofort den Wert verlieren. Genau so ist es auch mit dem Geld, also mit der Währung Euro, die verliert sofort an Wert, sobald die EU sagt, wir schaffen den Euro ab, also das könnte man ja machen. Und das ist aber der Irrglaube der Bitcoiner, dass sie etwas Intrinsisches herstellen können, dadurch, dass da irgendwelche Rechenleistungen vollbracht werden und sonst was. Nein, es ist einfach eine künstliche Verknappung. Im Prinzip könnte der Bitcoin Erfinder, wenn es ihn dann wirklich gibt, auch einfach selbst diese Bitcoin austeilen in Form von Dateien, die er verschickt, da bräuchte man gar nicht dieses Mining-System und würde einfach sagen, ja, ihr bekommt halt nur 150.000 oder wie viel auch immer. Mehr gibt es nicht. Und damit ist das knapp. Genauso wie in Mode-Konzernen wie Chanel jetzt einfach was verknappt und sagt, ab sofort darf jeder nur noch eine Chanel-Tasche im Jahr kaufen. Die machen halt eine künstliche Verknappung, um den Wert damit weiter hochzumachen. Bei Rolex ist das schon lange so und da hat sich jetzt noch mal verstärkt, weil viel Geld da ist und viel Nachfrage nach Rolex. Und die produzieren aber jetzt absichtlich nicht mehr, obwohl sie natürlich auch fünffach so viele Rolex wahrscheinlich produzieren könnten, wenn sie sich darauf einstellen. Aber es ist halt nicht gewollt. Und bei Bitcoin ist es eine künstliche Verknappung, die vorgenommen wird. Und dann hat man dieses FOMO Phänomen, dass Leute sagen, ach ja, moment, ich könnte was verpassen. Und das stimmt ja auch erst einmal, dass man sagt, gut, wenn jetzt gerade was da im Aufstieg ist und ich spreng da rechtzeitig auf den Zug auf, dann kann ich irgendwann wieder da raus und dann habe ich einen Gewinn gemacht. Das hat aber nichts mit irgendeinem intrinsischen Wert zu tun, sondern das ist reine Phantasmagorie.
Genau, also man muss das ganz deutlich sagen. Hier hören ja auch viele junge Männer zu, die gerne was mit Bitcoin machen. Bitcoin hat überhaupt nur einen Wert, weil wir unterstellen, dass er nächstes Jahr mindestens 20 Prozent mehr Euro oder Dollar wert ist. Ja, der Bitcoin selber bleibt der Bitcoin.
Und nicht, weil man damit irgendwas anfangen kann. Also nicht, weil man sagt, toll, Bitcoin will fix this, wie die dann immer drunterschreiben. Nee, der Bitcoin an sich ist reine Spekulation. Wir könnten jetzt auch sagen, wir machen das wie früher in den Niederlanden. Wir spekulieren jetzt wieder mit Tulpenzwiebeln. Könnte man ganz genau so machen, wäre ähnlich sinnlos.
Nur vielleicht ein bisschen weltfreundlicher. Da liegt ja noch eine gewisse Chance, denn die Tulpenzwiebel war mal super erfolgreich.
Wie auch Fälle, wenn man in diesen Büchern Geld im Mittelalter und so weiter nachliest, ist ja wirklich die, warum Gold? Und Gold hat ein paar Eigenschaften, die es im Nachhinein wirklich erklären, warum Gold jetzt die zentrale Rückzugswährung geworden ist, während man ganz früher noch wirklich Fälle einfach benutzt hat. Also kuschelige Fälle. Das war in der ästhetischen Kategorie ungefähr gleichauf mit Gold. Gold hat geglänzt und Fälle waren halt besonders anschmiegsam usw. Nur die Fälle konnte man halt nur zehnmal weitergeben und danach fühlte sich das nicht mehr gut an. Und Fälle ist auch… also man braucht sehr viel Logistik, um Fälle zu transportieren und das macht Gold halt super easy. Gold ist schon in ganz kleinen Mengen, also dadurch, dass es so knapp ist, in ganz kleinen Mengen wirklich zu unterscheiden von anderen Metallen, weil es glänzt einfach und es sieht gut aus. Und es kann dir in den Dreck fallen, du kannst es irgendwo einbuddeln. Am Ende kannst du es immer wieder einschmelzen, aus anderen Sachen rauskochen und dann hast du immer wieder das rohe Goldding. Also dieser berühmte Knopf, für den schon der Urvater damals einen Mantel kaufen konnte. Und heute kann man für den Wert eines Knopfes wieder einen ganzen Mantel kaufen und sich im Winter wärmen. Dieser Knopf ging halt wirklich nie verloren. Den konnte man, egal in welcher Form man den zwischendurch gebracht hat, immer wieder zurückführen. Und diese Eigenschaft hat Bitcoin nicht in sich. Bitcoin kann man nicht einfach weitergeben wie einen goldenen Knopf, weil Bitcoin erfordert, dass man Zugang zur Elektronik hat, Zugang zu Digitalen. Wenn die Welt untergeht und der Strom fällt aus, ist Bitcoin nichts wert. Und das wird immer wieder übersehen, wie kompliziert eigentlich das Hantieren mit Bitcoin ist. Und wir hören jetzt nochmal, ich habe es eben schon angekündigt, der Podcast heißt Bitcoin Fiat Rock'n'Roll von jemandem, der immer so 5-Minuten-Podcasts zum Thema macht. Und mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch für die Deutsche Bank oder so, arbeitet da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hier mal 45 Sekunden, wie sich zwei, die seit Ewigkeiten zu diesem ganzen Zeug Podcasten, einfach mal wundern, was jetzt Nachrichtenlage ist, nämlich, dass man Bitcoin jetzt verbrieft handeln kann.
Ich verstehe total, dass in der heutigen Situation es noch viele institutionelle Investoren gibt, die nicht direkt in Bitcoin investieren dürfen, können, wollen, aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen. Deswegen verstehe ich auch, dass es für die jetzt gerade Sinn ergeben könnte, in so einen Bitcoin ETF zu investieren. Mittel bis langfristig ist es ja aber so, dass wir hier ein Produkt Bitcoin, das extrem leicht investierbar und handelbar ist, noch mal über Futures-Märkte abbilden und dann noch mal einen ETF-Wrapper darum herumbauen, um dann da rein investieren zu können, obwohl eigentlich die Investition so schon sehr einfach ist. Es geht ja hier jetzt nicht so um so etwas wie Öl oder Weizen oder so, wo ich total verstehe, dass es da wichtige Futures-Märkte gibt, sondern es geht um Bitcoin.
Ja, und wenn Bitcoin will und Zugang zur Elektronik und Internet hat, da kann sich halt einfach einen auf die Wallet laden und dann ist fertig, das Kreuz und Quer zu verbriefen und dann noch mal einen Indexfond draus zu machen, das ist ja total sinnlos.
Es ist sinnlos, aber es funktioniert. Also das ist ja wieder das Erstaunliche bei den Finanzmärkten, dass es ja auch viele solche sinnlosen Futures gibt, die aber dann einfach funktionieren, weil man immer wieder auf dieses funktionierende Geschäft noch ein Geschäft drauflegen kann. Und dann kann man immer wieder aus der Wette noch eine Wette über die Wette machen und, und, und. Und so hat man da einen unglaublichen Markt aufgeblüßt, der allerdings natürlich realwirtschaftlich gar keinen Unterschied bringt. Und das ist natürlich auch das große Phantasma von Bukele, dass er diese hohen Zahlen sieht, sieht sein armes Land und denkt, ach ja, und dann sind wir ja reich, wenn wir auch diese ganzen Zahlen da irgendwie haben. Aber das macht natürlich nicht den Reichtum eines Landes aus. Aber Bukele wird jetzt, nachdem er verkündet hat, die Bitcoin City kommt, im nächsten Jahr fangen wir an zu bauen. Da wird er nochmal spirituell.
Also, es ist wahrscheinlich nicht egal, ob es für Bitcoin geht, aber ja, es ist egal für uns. Also, für irgendeine Grundlage, wenn du an Gott glaubst, wenn du nicht an Gott glaubst, die Natur, das Universum, für irgendeine Grundlage sind wir alle hier, jetzt hier, in Misata Beach, in El Salvador, Spaß haben, diese Projekte sehen, die Zukunft schauen, es ist schön, ein Teil davon zu sein, oder?
Es ist zum Schreien.
Ja, da kann man dann immer wieder sagen, dass wir nicht solchen Demagogen ausgesetzt sind. Bei uns ist vielleicht alles ein bisschen langsamer und ein bisschen träger und auch ein bisschen unklamorös und weiß ich nicht was. Aber dass man wirklich von solchen Wunderpredigern verschont bleibt, das ist so viel wert. Und man sieht aber auch, wie frustriert, glaube ich, so eine junge Generation ist, dass sie überhaupt einem solchen Kram an Heim fällt. Also dass man da nicht mal kurz überlegt, was erzählt er mir dann da eigentlich? Er stellt irgendein windiges Investorenprojekt vor und jetzt sagt er, es ist doch toll, dass wir alle, ob wir an Gott glauben oder nicht oder an die Kraft der Natur, dass wir nun Teil von all dem sind. Also es ist entsetzlich, diese Verblödung, die da mit einhergeht. Und selbst dann einige Bitcoin-Anhänger gucken mit Skepsis auf dieses Projekt. Mark Falzen hat eine Doku gedreht über Bitcoin in El Salvador und spricht jetzt da auch mit Leuten vor Ort, die das nicht so toll finden, was Bukele davor hat.
Ich habe sie gefragt, was sie über Bitcoin denkt. Und das ist nicht wie ein lokaler Mädchen, das ist das Mittelfinste, die rechte Stadt.
Das Versprechen von Bitcoin ist ja eigentlich so etwas wie Demokratisierung und man sieht dann schon hier bei solchen Punkten, dass es gar nicht darum geht, dass es demokratisiert, sondern da wird dann auch ganz schnell die Meinung von anderen Leuten unterdrückt und Mark Felsen ist ein Bitcoin-Anhänger oder steht ihm zumindest sehr offen gegenüber und findet das aber jetzt hier problematisch, auch weil er einfach mal den Praxistest macht. Es gibt also diese App Shivo, die hat jetzt jeder in El Salvador sich runterladen können und hat dann auch so ein bisschen Begrüßungsgeld bekommen und kann jetzt angeblich damit überall kaufen. Na ja, und es gibt eigentlich da von Anfang an Probleme.
At Starbucks, he can't buy anything with Bitcoin, with lightning for less than five dollars. So he gets extra food so we can show how it works. And he gets five dollars and 30 cents of food. And we're in there for like 30 minutes waiting for it to go through and it just failed. So we ended up paying in cash anyway.
Wenn man einfach mal irgendwo dann 30 Minuten warten muss, bis man dann toll mit dem Bitcoin bezahlen kann.
Echt wahnsinnig dumm.
Ja, man hat Bargeld. Man könnte das einfach auf den Tisch legen und gehen und sagen, ist gut so und macht es sich aber dann kompliziert, weil man irgendwie sagt, ach, das ist ja jetzt ganz modern. Er beschreibt dann nochmal hier kurz, was beim Lounge alles so schiefgelaufen ist.
Die Erwähnung von Bitcoin in El Salvador ist, dass Menschen die Möglichkeit haben, eine peer-to-peer-Kurzine zu haben, eine, die sie sich verhandeln können, eine, die sie sich überholt haben können. Und das ist das Gegenteil von dem, was passiert ist. Und als jemand, der Bitcoin unterstützt, schaue ich an, was passiert ist, und denke, das ist nicht Bitcoin. Denn die Bitcoin-Fraktion ist so grundlegend kaputt.
Wir müssen noch mal ganz kurz über Bukele sprechen. Seine Idee ist die folgende. Wenn ein Prozent aller Bitcoins in El Salvador liegen, investiert sind, dann würde sich das Protoinlandsprodukt auf, ich glaube, 25 Prozent erhöhen. Das ist irgendwie sein Fantasme. Ich denke, ja, diese eine Prozent, das müsste ich doch kriegen. Und dann sind wir doch auch ein reiches Land. Und hier beim CNBC-Podcast wurde dann mal darauf hingewiesen, dass das nur Nummern sind, nur Zahlen sind. Und es geht um was anderes.
Aus vielen Richtungen kriegen wir immer wieder mit, dass Geld gar nicht das Problem ist. Klimaanpassung, Infrastrukturentwicklung, Pandemiebekämpfung, an Geld mangelt es nicht. Also wenn es nur hieße, Geld auszugeben, das ließe sich organisieren.
Oder einfach mal da Geld zu parken. Du kannst einfach sagen, ich parke jetzt mal in El Salvador mein Geld, aber davon hat El Salvador erstmal nichts.
Genau, also mit Geld kann man erstmal alles machen. Die Frage ist, kriegt man Geld als Medium so gemanagt, dass man wirklich was erschafft, dass wirklich jemand die Schippe in die Hand nimmt und die Autobahn mit Solarplatten überdacht.
Ja.
Aber das scheint Bukele nicht bedacht zu haben.
Nee, er meint, mit dem Geld wird es schon irgendwie sich dann alles herstellen. Und Samson Mao war ja eben auf der Bühne von Blockstream und er ist jetzt noch mal im Interview mit Bloomberg Technology. Und die Interviewerin fragt jetzt, warum man denn eigentlich als institutioneller Anleger überhaupt diese Bonds, diese Anleihe da braucht?
Und ich frage mich, warum ein Institutionale Investorenbonds das kaufen würde?
Ja, aber dieses Bonds hat eine Bitcoin-Komponente und deshalb ist es ein Bitcoin-Bond. Also wenn El Salvador 1 Billion Dollar in dieser ersten Anleihung aufbaut, werden 500 Millionen Euro für Bitcoin verwendet. Und dann gehen 500 Millionen Euro für Energie und Mining-Infrastruktur. Aber dann wird es auf ein Bitcoin-Komponente erhöht.
Es ist total absurd. Also was erzählt er denn da eigentlich? Also der ist es hat ja der Bond bringt jetzt eigentlich weniger, aber es ist halt ein Bitcoin Bond und Bitcoin ist ja wertvoll und steigt immer weiter. Und es ist es erinnert ein bisschen an die ersten Tage von Bitcoin, als alle merkten, ach so was mit Coin im Namen ist eigentlich ganz gut. Da kann man jetzt schnell nochmal an der Börse Geld verdienen. Nennen wir doch alles mit Coin bis zu Kodacoin oder so. Und hier sagt man auch näher so ein Bitcoin Bond für eine Bitcoin City. Das klingt doch erstmal aussichtsreich. Da werden sich schon genügend Dumme finden, die da mit investieren. Und sie fragt aber dann nochmal weiter nach.
Aber sie würden diese Bonds in ihren Mandaten halten lassen, glaubst du? Aber es ist nicht nur ein Bond, weil es mit Bitcoin zu tun ist. Und wie du sagst, werden 50% der Bonds im 5-Jährigen Zeitraum, wenn du das wiederholt, von Bitcoin aus in den Mandaten gebeten. Das ist wirklich für sie zu entscheiden.
Denn es ist ein normaler Bond, das nur eine große Schanke Bitcoin in der Börse hat.
Ja, das ist FOMO wieder. Wir können dann institutionellen Investoren, die bis jetzt noch nicht in Bitcoin investieren, dürfen sagen, es ist aber eigentlich eine Staatsanleihe. Ja, und damit kriegen wir das ganze Geld.
Aber es ist doch Bitcoin. Ja, ja, es ist Bitcoin. Aber ja, bei Bitcoin würden die auch nicht direkt investieren oder dürfen das nicht. Ja, aber die ist noch mal anders. Und er weiß sich dann auch gar nicht mehr zu helfen. Und ist sich aber dann jetzt plötzlich sicher, wie er da rauskommt. Denn eigentlich geht es jetzt auch gar nicht um den Bitcoin oder so, sondern um El Salvador. Also lieber nicht überprüfen, was man denn sagt, wenn man das überprüft. Es geht doch eigentlich darum, El Salvador zu helfen. Unglaublich. Es ist total absurd, aber diese Bitcoin-Jünger fahren dann zum Teil darauf ab. Es gibt dann da ganz viele hektische Videos bei YouTube und TikTok, wo die sagen, jetzt sehen wir hier, dass unsere Revolution begonnen hat und, und, und. Und so ist es auch mit Samson Mow, der jetzt nochmal die Zukunft des Geldes für uns umreißt. Und da spielen all die Institutionen, über die wir lesen konnten, bei Adam Tos keine Rolle mehr.
Meanwhile, though, of course, relations with the US and El Salvador from a government perspective seem to be unraveling. They're heading yet a further low at the moment. There are, of course, wars of relationships between El Salvador and the IMF. Does any of that matter to some of the investors that you're talking to?
They're only relevant because they can print money, they can make the SDR, they can make money out of thin air. You can't do that on a Bitcoin standard. It really takes us back to what money should be, which is just money, not a surveillance mechanism and not a tool to enforce your beliefs and economic policies on another nation.
Ja, das ist einfach perfekt. Du hast diese Bitcoin-Klientel, dieses Milieu, das uns immer mit der Geschichte in den Ohren liegt. Diese Zentralbanken, das ist total ins-transparent. Die denken sich da irgendwelche Modelle aus und dann spannt die das über die ganze Welt. Währenddessen sitzen die Bitcoin-Hinies in El Salvador und bauen sich irgendein Modell, wo sie sich irgendwas ausdenken mit irgendwelchen Staatsanleihen und dann dieses Konstrukt. Bitte nicht so genau hinschauen, es geht hier um die Hilfe für El Salvador. Und sie reproduzieren im Grunde genau die Welt, von der sie sich vorstellen, wie die eigentliche Welt Geldwelt ist. Von der sie sich aus den Gründen, weil sie so ist, wie sie sich die vorstellen, entfernen wollen mit ihrem eigenen Bitcoin, in dem dann endlich der Währungsfonds und so keine Rolle mehr spielt, der internationale Währungsfonds und alle, und baut aber gleichzeitig so eine Institution auf. Das ist ja so bescheuert eigentlich.
Und da trifft es dann auch wirklich zu. Also bei Lagarde können wir uns sicher sein, die wird jetzt sich nicht irgendwelche Staatsanleihen da irgendwie so monetarisieren können, dass sie jetzt am Ende mit zehn Milliarden rausgeht. Ja, sondern sie macht halt da ihren Dienst, denn sie will ja tatsächlich mit ihrer Politik, dass man Geld einfach als Geld begreift und damit umgeht und es nutzt, um damit dies und das zu ermöglichen. Also das, was er vom Bitcoin will, während er tatsächlich ja sich und viele andere da sich ein System gebastelt haben, bei dem sie sehr gut profitieren können und sie immer irgendwelche Mehrwerte aus diesen ganzen Vermittlungsrollen, die sie da spielen, abschöpfen können. Das ist auch bei dieser App Shivo natürlich sehr interessant. Die ist natürlich nicht rein staatlich, sondern ist privat aufgelegt worden. Und da fragt man sich natürlich auch bei diesen Kursschwankungen so, wer kann da eigentlich immer wieder draus abschöpfen? Also das ist eigentlich die Möglichkeit, um jetzt nochmal richtig kriminelle Geschäfte zu machen. Also noch viel mehr als was ohnehin schon. An den Finanzmärkten möglich ist. Es ist total absurd und da zu tun, als gings in irgendeiner Weise um Demokratisierung. Das ist einfach nur die Erzählung, die man denen einredet, die nicht die Möglichkeit haben, in dieser Weise da zu intrigieren.
Aber trotzdem, sie machen sich breit. Ich habe auch noch ein paar Krypto-Geschichten. Zum einen habe ich einen meiner Lieblings-Podcasts gehört, und der hier mal, der legt sich auch mal so eine Liste an Themen bereit, aus dem vollen Shop, aus dem vollen Schöpf. Es geht um das Stadion in Los Angeles.
Es ist ein schönes Facility. Und es ist dort wo die Clippers spielen und die Lakers spielen und es ist irgendwie bekannt, weil es ein großer Fernsehmarkt ist, jeder weiß es. Es ist jetzt die krypto.com Arena.
Ja, crypto.com, irgendeine Webseite, auf der man Kryptowährungen handeln kann, die irgendwo in Singapur oder so sitzen, keine Ahnung, und Geld da einstreichst, als ja, das kostet nämlich alles Geld. Es ist nicht einfach nur die Währung, organisiert sich alleine. Nee, da braucht man Institutionen für. Und die greifen ordentlich ab. Das Staple Center hat 1999 375 Millionen Baukosten verursacht. Die Namensrechte für 20 Jahre wurden jetzt für 700 Millionen Dollar an crypto.com gegeben. Da sieht man schon mal, das passt nicht ganz zusammen. Für die 700 Millionen hätte man sich auch ein eigenes Stadion noch mal bauen können. Man wollte aber da noch mal die zentrale Lage und so weiter. Und 700 Millionen für Namensrechte für eines Stadions. Also, irgendwer zockt hier die ganzen Crypto-Kiddies, die sich mit der ersten Wallet, die sie auf ihrem ersten Handy mit 14 Jahren gekriegt haben und so weiter, zockt die ganz schön ab. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, in welche Richtung das so geht. Ich erzähle jetzt eine kleine Geschichte vom November, die tatsächlich, und du hast jetzt das Realitätslevel ziemlich sozusagen in die Ferne getrieben. Also wir sehen jetzt, es ist wirklich alles möglich, was so erzählbar ist. Es ist keine Fanfiction, sondern ich erzähle jetzt, wie es war. Sotheby's, das Versteigerungshaus in New York, hat eine der zehn Originalabschriften der US-Constitution angeboten. Also die noch sozusagen mit den Originalunterschriften und so wie auch immer. Der Gründungsväter Pipapo, ein richtig wertvolles altes Dokument. Da kann man sich eine Seite so eingerahmt an die Wand hängen und sagen, ich habe hier eine der zehn Ursprungsfassungen der Verfassung der Vereinigten Staaten Amerikas. Und die ist natürlich viel wert. Die Frage ist, wie viel? Na ja, das muss man dann klären bei Sotheby's. Deswegen ist sie eine Versteigerung. Es wird also angesetzt, 17. November, wir versteigern die Constitution. Jetzt denken sich einige Krypto-Hainis. Wir finden ja die Institutionen eh alle blöd. Also mobilisieren wir jetzt Krypto-Geld, um die dann aufzukaufen. Es hat sich also eine DAO, eine Digital- oder Decentral-Autonomous-Organisation gegründet.
Über Reddit oder was?
Nee, über Ether. Es gibt ja Ethereum, also Bitcoin, nur mit einer Ankoppelung an intelligente Verträge, Smart Contracts und so weiter. Und da kann man auch solche Organisationen gründen, um dann zweckgebunden, da kriegt nämlich dann jeder, der da einzahlt, ein gewisses Stimmenrecht innerhalb. So wird alles digital organisiert. Naja, die haben sich jedenfalls in Aufgabe gestellt. Okay, also machen wir diesen Topf jetzt auf. Alle können ihr Geld da reinwerfen. Natürlich zahlt man den Dollar ein, das muss aber dann umgewandelt werden, erst in Ether und so weiter. Wir sammeln also ganz viel Geld, um dann an einer Versteigerung teilzunehmen. Das ist natürlich schon mal das Problem. Diese Dezentrale Autonom-Organisation ist ja öffentlich. Man kann ja sehen, in welchem Zustand sie gerade ist. Also sieht man auch, die haben jetzt 40 Millionen gesammelt. Also wird das ja wohl das höchste Gebot sein, was die in der Lage sind, abzugeben. Konnten also alle anderen Teilnehmer der Versteigerung sehen. Ah ja, gut, die bieten gleich bis 40 Millionen mit und danach sind die raus. Naja, man spricht bei rice.com, die das nochmal aufgedröselt haben, als Geschichte von einem Ad-hoc-Mob of Krypto-Investors. Das fand ich ziemlich gut. Ad-hoc-Mob. Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Gamestop. Da ist eine Gelegenheit, man organisiert das, gibt es bekannt über Reddit und so weiter, Twitter, YouTube und dann sammelt sich das so zusammen. Und naja, der 17. November naht. Man ist zwei Wochen lang am Organisieren. Zuerst sind es so 10 Millionen Dollar, 20 Millionen, und dann die letzten drei Tage tatsächlich 40 Millionen Dollar ist das Gebot. Sie verlieren aber die US-Constitution, die sie kaufen wollten, um sie einem Museum zu geben, mit der Bedingung, ihr dürft sie dann öffentlich ausstellen, wenn ihr ein Zettel dazu legt, dieses Worte mit einem Ether-organisierten DAO und so weiter gekauft. Also man wollte sozusagen groß auftrumpfen und zeigen, wir haben die alten Institutionen zertrümmert, am Beispiel, wir haben es geschafft, die in die Verfassung zu kaufen. Sie sind dann aber gescheitert, denn die Gebote waren ja einsehbar, 40 Millionen. Man wusste, das ist das Höchstgebot. Also hat Ken Griffin einfach 43 Millionen geboten. Das ist der Chef von Citadel. Citadel wiederum ist der Hedgefonds, der damals als die ganzen Robinhood, ich kaufe mir auch mal schnell eine GameStop-Aktie, Leute Melvin Capital klein hauen wollten. Und damals hat Citadel seinen Kollegen Hedgefonds von Melvin Capital einfach 2, 7 Milliarden überwiesen, damit die ihren Betrieb weiter aufrechterhalten konnten. Und wenn man dann in Wikipedia nachliest, dann kommen dann auch so kleine Fun-Facts wie, dass Citadel auch mal nebenbei 800.000 Dollar an Janet Yellen zahlt, damit sie so ein Webinar macht und so. Also diese typische amerikanische Korruption, wie wir sie so kennen. Naja, jedenfalls ist es dann so gewesen, dass dieser DAO gescheitert ist, also die Krypto-Leute sind da gescheitert und haben 40 Millionen organisiert, mobilisiert, die dann nicht benutzt werden konnten, um die Constitution, also dieses Dokument zu kaufen.
Das macht man also mit diesem Geld.
Genau, was macht man mit diesem Geld?
In El Salvador hat man ja auch schon sehr viel Geld eingesammelt, immer mal wieder für so Spendenaktionen. Zum Beispiel hat man da ein Krankenhaus für Haustiere eröffnet.
Das ist ziemlich gut. Das ist wie das Kinderwagen-Museum in der Lausitz, was aus dem Strukturfonds Kohleausstieg jetzt bezahlt wurde, weil die Orte vor Ort nicht mehr wussten, wohin mit dem Geld. 17 Milliarden. Ach ja, komm, wir machen ein Museum für Kinderwagen. Naja, aber wohin mit dem Geld? Nur weil ein Dau 40 Millionen equivalente ETH sammelt, heißt das ja noch nicht, dass dieses Geld in welcher Form eigentlich irgendwie zur Verfügung steht. Leo Laporte liest hier mal aus dem Rice-Artikel über die Frage, wie konnte man da eigentlich investieren, wie hat man sich beteiligt, in welcher Form liegt dieses Geld jetzt eigentlich vor?
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, dass es ein bisschen mehr zu tun hat. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, dass es ein bisschen mehr zu tun hat.
Gas-Fees sind so die Transaktionskosten, die anfallen. Gibt's ja in zweifacher Hinsicht auch zeitlich und sachlich. Also es kostet erstmal Geld, aber dann auch zeitlich. Man steht halt in dem Kaffeebude in El Salvador erstmal fünf Minuten rum, bis die Blockchain soweit ist, dass sie das mal verifiziert und so weiter.
Krypto-Währungen sind das große Geschäft für Intermediäre. Also gerade zu denken, die Krypto-Währung funktioniert so, dass wir den Staat nicht mehr brauchen, all das nicht mehr brauchen. Wir tauschen das unter uns aus bedeutet, es gibt Intermediäre, die unendlich viel Geld abschöpfen, während wir tatsächlich, wenn ich dir jetzt 100 Euro überweise, halt unsere normale Gebühr, vielleicht eine Überweisungsgebühr zahlen, je nachdem, welches Kontomodell wir haben. Aber es ist nicht der Rede wert, während es mit Krypto richtig teuer wird, wovon andere profitieren, zum Beispiel dann auch so ein Samson Mao, der dann da locker sitzt und sagt, ja wir retten ja hier El Salvador.
Ja oder krypto.com, die dann einfach, ach ja, 700 Millionen für die.
Kein Problem.
Kein Problem, ja. Wir holen uns die Namenrechte her. Da ist das Geld hingeflossen. Also die bei weis.com haben einen Selbstversuch gemacht, wollten sich mit 200 Dollar beteiligen, das Geld einmal hin überwiesen, hat schon 75 Dollar Gebühren gekostet, dann hat es ja nicht geklappt, also wollte man sein Geld wieder zurück, das hat nochmal 75 Dollar gekostet und der Rest ging auch für alles mögliche drauf. Also das Geld ist einfach irgendwo versickert und man weiß nicht genau wo. Und die Hälfte der Leute, die da teilgenommen haben, haben zum allerersten Mal da teilgenommen und sehr viele Wallets wurden überhaupt dafür eingerichtet. Also das ist sozusagen für sehr viele die Primärerfahrung, die sie jetzt mit Krypto-Zeug gemacht haben. Und als wäre das alles nicht so schon schlimm genug, Jeff Jarvis hat dir das mal super auf den Punkt gebracht mit einer einfachen Frage. Ja, hätte man nicht einfach seine Dollar, die man ja eh hat auf so ein Kickstarter-Ding, dafür ist doch Kickstarter da, ja stimmt. Und wenn es nicht klappt, dann gibt man es halt wieder zurück. Dann fließt das einfach wieder zurück. Also in der Ansicht ist es eine wahnsinnig bescheuerte Geschichte. Gehen wir mal in dein Metier, Film. Quentin Tarantino, cooler Name, cooler Gast auf der einen oder anderen Konferenz, kümmert sich jetzt auch sehr um Krypto-Zeug. Und er war zu Besuch bei NFTNYC, also einer New Yorker NFT-Krypto-Konferenzveranstaltung irgendwie. Eigentlich ein recht kleiner Rahmen, viel zu klein für ihn. Er stand dann so ein bisschen verloren auf der Bühne und hat da irgendwie sowas für 200 Leute erzählt. Na ja, Karas Wischer in ihrem Pivot-Podcast spielt mal einen Clip davon, wie sich Tarantino dort hat erklären lassen, was NFTs sind und wie sie funktionieren. Und wenn du findest, NFTs sind komisch, du bist nicht allein. Hier ist ein Clip von jemanden, der sie Quentin Tarantino an einem Event hat, in dem er die Säle erprobt hat.
Wenn du die ganze Fram von Pulp Fiction, die Schott, in der die beiden von ihnen die Waffe halten, in der es so ist, wie die Memen-Image, du, das würde sicherlich für Millionen verkaufen.
Zehn Millionen?
Das klingt wie ein klugloser Dork.
Wie ist das anders als die Stille, die bereits existieren?
Die Image der NFT ist nicht das Ding, es ist die Gefühl der Wohne-Wohnung.
Jetzt, wenn du sie hast, sind wir jetzt auf der Blockchain.
Das ist wo NFT's interessant werden.
An dem Level der Blockchain, denk an diese Image, als ob sie eine Matrix-Kode in der Filmwahl haben.
Reden wir über das, weil viele Arten das machen, um ihre IP zu zurücknehmen, die sie auf Hollywood-Kompanien verkaufen.
So, Tarantino hat die Deals schon am Laufen, aber lässt sich hier nochmal anstacheln. Was wäre dann, wenn man einzelne Frames aus Filmen, beispielsweise hier Samuel L. Jackson und John Travolta halten ihre Waffen in die Kamera? Sehr berühmtes Bild aus Pipe Fiction. Wenn man das einfach rausnimmt, isoliert, und den einzelnen Frame per NFT verhökert, nämlich in der Hinsicht, ja, hängt überall natürlich in Kopie rum, aber das Originalbild ist deins. Also mit diesem NFT-Versprechen, nur du kennst das Passwort zu diesem Bild, was auch immer dieses Passwort dann am Ende materiell wert ist, nämlich gar nichts.
Aber es ist ja auch total unsinnig wieder. Also unsinniger geht es ja nicht. Also ich kann dir sagen, ich kaufe ein Gemälde, weil ich weiß, die beste Reproduktion wird nie so sein, wie das Gemälde. Das ist ja überhaupt die Existenzberechtigung auch für Museen, denn an sich könnte man sagen, schick mir doch ein paar hoch aufgelöste Fotos. Warum noch in irgendein Museum gehen? Man weiß aber, wenn man die Präsenz eines Kunstwerkes hat, man die Farben so sieht, wie sie sind, wenn man dem gegenüber steht, ist das etwas anders. Beim NFT habe ich genau das nicht, sondern ich habe nur irgendeinen Code, von dem ich ja im Prinzip auch nur glauben muss, dass es diesen Code gibt. Ich kann ja gar nichts mehr in dem Sinne mit anstellen. Das ist irgendwas für Informatiker vielleicht noch. Es ist also vollkommen nach Homburg. Also man kann das aus allem machen. Also wir könnten jetzt diesen Podcast auch als NFT anbieten und sagen, ja gut, jeder hört jetzt den Podcast hier. Aber du, der du 10.000 Euro bezahlst, du bekommst den Originalpodcast, denn der hat diesen einen tollen Code. Also vielleicht ist jemand so verrückt. Gerne, ich nehme die 10.000, aber das muss man sich mal so wirklich in diesem Wahnsinn vorstellen.
Genau, es ist Quatsch. Es ist so richtiger Quatsch. Der einzige Unterschied wäre noch, wenn man wie Christopher Nolan nur auf Film dreht, der später digitalisiert wird, kann man den Originalfilm vor seiner Digitalisierung noch als das einzigartige, den haben wir tatsächlich belichtet.
Den kann man dann zwar nichts machen, manche sammeln ja Filmrollen und das ist auch ganz gut, wenn man später nochmal das Material direkt abgreifen will. Könnte ja mal sein, dass es irgendwas Besseres gibt als Blu-ray, dann kann man es immer brauchen.
Genau, aber typischerweise wird heute eigentlich direkt digital gefilmt, direkt auf dem Chip und damit ist das Ding so oft kopierbar, ohne dass sich die Duplikate irgendwie voneinander unterscheiden. Es macht alles keinen Sinn, aber die Streiterei läuft. Also Scott Galloway beschreibt hier kurz. Miramax ist ein Produzent oder wie auch immer Verleiher, wie heißt das da in der Filmbranche?
Produktionsfirma ist das glaube ich.
Also Miramax, die das für Tarantino da immer alles organisiert haben und so weiter, mit denen er dies gemacht hat. Die streiten sich jetzt wirklich darum, wem gehören die NFTs aus den Filmen, also einzelne Standbilder der Filme.
Die Leute lieben es, Wert und Werte in der Klasse zu signalieren, indem sie das einzige Wunder von etwas sind, das einzigartig und interessant ist. Die Medien-Assätze sind wirklich einzigartig und interessant.
Und es wird die Werte von Medien-
Und ich denke, Miramax wird das gewinnen. Miramax hat gesagt, schau, das ist eine intellektuelle Wohnung, von einem Asset, den wir finanziert haben und den wir auch die.
Wenn er sich die Bilder von ihm schreiben will, oder von ihm, wenn er einen Kaffee trinkt, bei der Pressekonferenz, dann vielleicht.
Dass es ein echter Rechtsstreit zwischen Miramax und Tarantino gerade.
Ja, nachdem du jetzt diese verrückte Community da in El Salvador erlebt hast, ist doch wirklich alles möglich. Also das ist für mich das verrückteste, was ich in diesem Monat gehört habe, das mit El Salvador und jetzt höre ich aber das und weiß gar nicht, ob das nicht vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen bescheuerter ist. Miramax ist ja eine Produktionsfirma, die von den Weinsteinbrüdern gegründet wurde. Ist natürlich da auch durch viele Hände geflossen. Dann wurden Anteile an Miramax Ende 2013 an Qatar Investment Authority verkauft. Und 2016 wurde Miramax von Qatar Investment Authority an die BN Media Group mit Sitz in Doha, Katar verkauft. Also da werden jetzt diese Rechtsstreitlichkeiten, also finden jetzt da transnational statt, wenn man so möchte. Da werden also Schiedsgerichte sich sehr auf freuen drüber. Es ist absolut absurd, aber irgendwie auch erschreckend, dass Terntino sich mit so einem Mist abgibt.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht, ob man, als ob nicht irgendwann einfach mal genug ist. Ja, war bei Bukele schon die Frage. Kann nicht einfach mal genug sein. Leo Laporte greift das Thema auch noch mal auf, denn es geht nicht nur um einzelne Standbilder aus den Filmen, sondern... Also Tarantino saß irgendwie da, hat sich aufstacheln lassen von irgendwer und hat dann ja ich könnte doch das Skript jetzt noch mal nachträglich verhökern und dann das und das und so und das ist wirklich so Banane aber liegt da nicht an. Das ist doch eine Chance insoweit, dass Scott Galloway irgendwie überzeugt, die NFTs spielen natürlich dann im Metaverse, je nachdem, in welcher Form wir das dann haben, noch eine große Rolle. Denn da kann man ja solche Sachen dann wirklich benutzen. Also im Metaverse, in dieser virtuellen Realität könnte man sich ja eine Hütte einrichten, in der dann das Originalposter an der Wand hängt. Und man kann aber gleichzeitig dafür Sorge tragen, dass es nie, dass es nirgendwo anders hängt. Weil es wäre eben wirklich non-fangible.
Würdest du sagen, jetzt beim Metaverse bezogen ist das von dir auf das Zuckerberg-Metaverse oder auf Metaverse in grundsätzlicher Weise, dass man sagt, ja, wir werden da so etwas doch ähnliches, wie Zuckerberg es vorschwebt, generell bekommen. Dass es da so eine digitale Welt ist, die wir mit Kunstwerken ausstatten, in der wir digitales Geld haben und und und. Und da begeben wir uns dann ab und an, so wie wir lustig sind, hinein. Oder würdest du sagen, gut, das ist diese komische Zuckerberg-Fantasie gespeist aus. Ich will in Konferenzen Menschen direkt in die Augen blicken, wenn ich online mit ihnen spreche und und und. Wir haben das ja mal besprochen. Also siehst du da jetzt wirklich noch so eine Chance in Metaverse, also dass es für eine große Anzahl von Menschen etwas Erstrebenwertes dann doch sein wird?
Also nur in Spielen und ganz spezifischen Unterhaltungssegmenten. Da kann ich mir das vorstellen, dass man sich wirklich zu Hause hinsetzt, die Brille aufsetzt und dann plötzlich bei einem Coldplay-Konzert ist. Zweite Reihe und man sieht das dann genau von da unten und wird dann auch angesungen. Ist sehr aufwendig zu produzieren, also wird kein Massending. Bei Spielen wird es allerdings ein Massending und da glaube ich auch, und das sieht man ja heute schon, einzelne Waffen, einzelne Pokémons und so weiter. Die sind natürlich, die funktionieren wie NFTs. Die muss man sich verdienen, die muss man kaufen, wie auch immer. Da muss man auch echtes Geld mitbringen. Die haben auch eine echte Funktion im Spiel, also wenn man sich dann Sachen kauft, kommt man auch wirklich weiter. Also da würde ich sagen, spielt das eine Rolle, ob das jetzt für Tarantino ein Szenario gibt, wo irgendwie Leute sich so privat einrichten und die werden dann sozusagen in ihrer virtuellen Hütte besucht und dann hängt da ein Foto an der Wand. Und das ist aber dann das Eindeutige und so. Ja, das finde ich dann sehr merkwürdig. Also in der Ansicht würde ich sagen, Tarantino spielt ja gerade einen Fall durch, der nie eine große Rolle spielen wird. Aber trotzdem spielt er etwas durch, das dann auf anderen Gebiete für andere Anbieter von NFTs eine große Rolle spielen wird. Nämlich dann, wenn man so spielt. Also ich denke vor allem an Spiele. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man irgendwann in einem Konferenzraum sitzt und dann setzen sich alle mal eine Brille auf, weil sie gerne mit Singapur zusammen so eine 3D-Sitzung machen wollen. Und es sind aber nicht alle da oder so. Die werden Video telefonieren wie je und je. Also in der Ansicht sehr komisch. Joshua und Ryan Hollien oder wie auch immer es heißt, also der andere Tomorrow Podcast, den es da noch gibt, die spekulieren hier so ein bisschen, ob das nicht auch noch eine Chance für Elon Musk ist, ein paar Werte zu generieren. Denn Elon Musk, anders als andere CEOs, ist natürlich medial immer sehr präsent. Gerade da, wo Memes sehr bedeutsam sind. Das wir nicht ganz klar machen. Mal sehen, ob Elon Musk ja auch sehr geschäftstüchtig und sehr Bitcoin-affin ist und uns demnächst auch nochmal mit irgendeinem Abverkauf überrascht, wenn er hier mit irgendwelchen Dingern um die Ecke kommt. Eine Sache, die allerdings super interessant und mich auch ein bisschen euphorisch stimmt, denn es gibt durchaus ein Gebiet, auf dem wir, da gehen wir jetzt ein bisschen weg von Bitcoin, aber bleiben bei Finanzierungen und Memes und vor allem Personen, also wir reden hier über Influencer. Ich höre so den Twig-Podcast von Leo Laporte und da wird folgendes mit... Und mit Sam ist hier Sam Lesson gemeint, jemand so aus dieser Gegend da, wo es digital zugeht im Westen Amerikas.
Er hat seine eigene Investition, eine VC-Firma, Slow Ventures. Und statt von Investitionen in Start-ups und in Unternehmen, haben sie sich auf Investitionen in Kreatoren entschieden.
So, du hast ja ein Buch über Influencer geschrieben.
Ja.
Influencer sind nicht weit von Creators entweckt. Es ist irgendwie ein bisschen dasselbe, wenn auch Creator nochmal auch auf anderes Wert legen, als nur Werbekörper zu sein, sagen wir mal so.
Genau.
Und die Influencer sind ja zunächst einmal frei. Also sie sind selbstständig. Natürlich sind sie dann oft auch in Agenturen eingebunden, aber sie sind frei, suchen sich ihre Kooperationspartner selbst, müssen auch sehen, dass sie attraktiv bleiben für den Markt, müssen sich auf neuen Plattformen umtun, um auf Dauer ihren Erfolg ausbauen zu können.
So, und besteht da die Möglichkeit, eine bisher übersehene Investitionsmasse vorzufinden, dass man irgendwie sagt, hm, ich investiere in diesen Influencer. Die Frage ist dann, wie und so. Sie machen sich hier so ein paar Gedanken. Wir sind also in der Twig-Folge 638. Ich bin ja kein Creator, sondern einfach nur ein Buchautor, du auch. Das heißt, zu uns kommen Verlage und sagen dann, wir geben dir ein kleines Startkapital, eine Druckerei, einzelne Services, die man so braucht, wie Korrekturlesen und so weiter. Man hat dann also in eine Buchidee investiert, am Ende ist ein Buch entstanden und dann wird das verkauft und die Erträge werden dann anteilig, je nach Aufwand und so weiter, verteilt. Also die Autoren kriegen Vorschuss und dann 10% der Abverkäufe, die Verlage übernehmen ein bisschen unternehmerisches Risiko und so weiter. Dann ist es so eine Symbiose aus dem einzelnen Schöpfer und der Logistik dahinter. Und dann hat man so... Und die sagen jetzt, nee, wir investieren einfach in die Person. Da muss keine Idee dahinter hängen oder ein Projekt, sondern es ist einfach nur die Person. Und das war dann ganz interessant, denn sie hatten dann Sam Lessin tatsächlich zu Gast eine Folge später, also this week in Google, 639. Und Leo Laporte führt noch mal mit dieser allgemeinen Idee ein, wie investiert man eigentlich in Amerika, also dieses ganze Wagniskapital und so weiter. So, und da hatte sich ja das Wagniskapital hinsichtlich technologischer Entwicklung immer schon ein bisschen wegentwickelt von dieser Projektidee, ja, bis hin zu Microsoft Cloud Wunderlist, aber nicht, weil sie die Wunderlist-App so toll finden, sondern weil das einfach fünf Leute sind, die sich mit Technik auskennen, die sich organisieren können, die ein Produkt erschaffen können und die möchten wir gerne bei uns haben. Wir investieren also in Menschen und ihre Ideen und nicht so sehr in das Produkt, wie man noch in Filme oder Bücher oder sonstiges investiert.
Wie man ja früher im Hollywood-System, heute ist das ein bisschen anders, aber früher im Hollywood-System der 30er- 40er-Jahre auch investierte in Regisseure oder Schauspieler, ohne dass da jetzt schon konkret was ausgemacht war. Sondern man hat gesehen, das ist jemand, der Talent hat oder sieht gut aus, könnte jetzt unser möglicher Star werden. Und dann investierte man in der Form, dass man also dieser Person einen Vertrag aufsetzte und dann sagte, du verpflichtest dich dazu, die nächsten acht Jahre für die Paramount zu arbeiten und bekommst, wenn kein Film entsteht, so und so viel. Wenn ein Film entsteht, dann dies und das und je nachdem. Und damit konnte man aber auch Leute im Prinzip töten für den Markt. Also man hat beispielsweise Leute nicht mehr aus dem Vertrag gelassen, die woanders Angebote hatten. Und wollte aber nicht, dass die das bekommen. Oder man hat Leute engagiert und dann nichts mit ihnen angefangen, weil man dachte, so teuer ist das Investment nicht, dann lassen wir die lieber mal liegen. Zum Beispiel Hildegard Knef hatte, als sie nach Amerika ging, einen solchen Vertrag bekommen, ich glaube sogar von David O. Selznick, also dem Produzenten von Vom Winde verweht. Und dann machte man nichts mit ihr. Sie war dann einfach zwei, drei Jahre in Hollywood, traf Leute, durfte mal irgendwo einen unbedeutenden Film drehen, aber eigentlich machte man nichts mit ihr. Und in der Zeit konnte sie aber auch nicht frei agieren. Oder ein anderer Fall ist Tippi Hedren. Die hatte einen Festvertrag, dass Hitchcock mit ihr arbeiten konnte. Und dann hat Hitchcock dafür gesorgt, als sie nicht sich gefügig genug zeigte, dass sie woanders keine Filme machen konnte. Also das hat man auch immer wieder gemacht. Aber da kann man sehen, hat man auf jeden Fall erst mal so in das Humankapital investiert und geguckt, was daraus wird.
Genau, ist so ein bisschen geblieben in der Musik, wenn man einzelnen Künstlern gesagt hat, die nächsten fünf Alben bei uns, das ist dann der berühmte Plattenvertrag, egal was dann kam. Also David Bowie oder Gabriel oder so, die haben dann, ich mache jetzt mal Weltmusik oder so, da musste der Verlag halt damit leben, dass das jetzt das nächste Album ist. Aber wenn die fünf Alben kamen, wussten halt alle, ok, jetzt ist er wieder auf dem Markt. Jetzt müsste man entweder ein neues Angebot machen oder jemand anders greift zu. Und so ist das jetzt hier auch. Also der Sam Lessin, den wir dann gleich hören, der hat Marina Mogilko, die ist eine supersympathische junge Frau, die auf YouTube unter dem Accountnamen Lingua Marina 5 Millionen Abonnenten und so weiter einfach nur so kurz Videos macht, wie man ordentlich Englisch spricht. Sie selbst ist irgendwie aus Russland, als Kind nach Amerika gekommen, hat dann also Englisch als Fremdsprache gelernt und kann jetzt da so ein bisschen reflektieren, wie spricht man eigentlich ordentlich Englisch, wie bringt man sich das ordentlich bei, also wenn man so gut Englisch kann, aber dann noch mal so die letzten Schliffe, damit man irgendwie wie eingeboren klingt. Eigentlich gar nicht so spektakulär, aber man hat ihr jetzt einfach 1, 7 Millionen Dollar gegeben und gesagt, alle zukünftigen Einnahmen, die du als Creator erzielst, davon gehen 5% an uns. Und dann kann man ja jeder überlegen, wird sich das rechnen? Ja, nein. Sie müsste also so und so viele Millionen in ihrer Lebensphase die nächsten 40 Jahre verdienen, damit sich das für die rechnet.
Über so lange hat man das ausgedehnt?
Ja, irgendwie so die nächsten 30 Jahre, 5%, und dafür kriegt sie als Startkapital 1, 7 Millionen Dollar. Also so ungefähr ist der Vertrag geregelt. So richtig in die Karten schauen lässt er sich da nicht, aber er erklärt es hier so ein bisschen. Zum Beispiel hat er diese Idee schon relativ früh gehabt mit Lifecapital. Das war so seine Idee. So könnte man sowas nicht.
Ich habe eine Firma startet, ich habe noch in meinem Domain, lifecapital.com, um das zu versuchen, das zu machen.
Das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut. Das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht gut, das ist nicht. Nur die schauen sich ja die Leute an und fragen, würden die das dann wirklich machen? Und da ist hier bei der Marina jemand, wo man echt sieht, okay, also die hat da echt Spaß dran, die macht das einfach aus Freude. Der kann man mit dem Geld jetzt einfach sagen, du kannst jetzt das, was du gerade machst, immer weitermachen, du musst nicht mehr um deine Existenz fürchten, je nachdem wie viel du verdienst. Also man kann sozusagen den Kopf frei schaffen. Und das ist natürlich eine echte Neuerung. Und klappt natürlich nur, weil das an nichts Weiteres gewunden ist, außer geh deiner Leidenschaft nach. Aber such dir nicht noch was anderes zum Broterwerb, sondern deine Leidenschaft kann ab jetzt reichen. Also das ist sozusagen dieses Versprechen, dass sie hier...
Das ist einer meiner Risiken.
Wenn nichts stattfindet, findet nichts statt.
In der Wahrheit ist es das Gegenteil.
Wir haben eine Struktur, wo wir eine Idee haben, das ist nicht sogar ein Teil des Deal.
Wenn man nämlich nicht mehr Creator ist, ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich doch auch juristisch absichern, denn wahrscheinlich könnten sie sich gar nicht an allem beteiligen. Also da gäbe es wahrscheinlich auch einfach so eine Schranke, die ein paar Richter dann aufziehen. Aber er sagt es deswegen hier nochmal ganz deutlich.
andere Leute, die nicht du sind, machen das gleiche, machen das gleiche, das ist aus dem Deal.
Wir sagen, wir investieren in dich, in die Qualität deines Kreatoren-Brandes.
Jetzt kann natürlich ein Staat nicht sagen, wir statten jeden mit 1, 7 Millionen. Wir können ja jetzt mal überlegen, was das denn eigentlich jetzt auf einem anderen Niveau bedeutet, dass man ohne einen gewissen Druck arbeiten kann oder sich erst einmal selbst verwirklichen kann. Wir haben es ja durch Bologna dazu gebracht, jetzt an den Universitäten, dass alle möglichst schnell studieren müssen, durchkommen müssen, diese Scheine sammeln müssen und auch schon Studienkredite aufgenommen haben, zu wenig BAföG erhalten und so weiter, müssen nebenher Mini-Jobs machen und haben so dann am Ende des Studiums vielleicht schon Schulden. Zumindest hatten sie nicht den Freiraum, um auch noch andere Dinge zu machen. Leute, die in Ausbildungen sind, müssen ihrer Ausbildung nachgehen und haben dann Freizeit, aber da ist wenig Platz, um noch was anderes zu machen und man ist gleich in diesem Proterwerb-Modus drin. Eine gewisse finanzielle Unabhängigkeit kann natürlich gegeben sein, wenn man von Hause aus reich ist, aber was sich ja daraus zeigt, ist, dass die Ungleichheit damit sich noch verstärkt, denn die, die von Hause aus reich sind, haben damit mehr Zeit, können sich mehr mit ihren Dingen beschäftigen, werden darin besser in dem, was sie eigentlich tun. Insofern haben sie einen noch größeren Vorsprung gegenüber den anderen. Eigentlich ist es ja die sozial-staatliche Aufgabe, genau diesen Vorsprung zu minimieren, nicht indem man das den reichen Leuten verbietet, dass sie sich selbst verwirklichen, sondern dass man es den anderen ermöglicht.
Und da wäre ja, genau, und da wäre, Das ist die FDP, die neue Regierung, eigentlich total dafür.
Ja, komischerweise aber dann nicht, was Sozialausgaben anbelangt, denn dann hätte man ja tatsächlich mal mehr Geld in die Hand genommen. Und deswegen ist es ja doch ganz entscheidend, eigentlich zu sagen, muss man nicht eigentlich Menschen es ermöglichen, dass sie überhaupt mal diese Talente, die sie haben, sie ausprobieren können. Was jetzt nicht bedeutet, jeder bekommt jetzt mal fünf Jahre Freie und kann machen, was er will. Das ist ja jetzt hier auch auf ganz wenige Personen reduziert. Aber ich glaube schon, dass man nicht ignorieren kann, wie hoch der finanzielle Druck ist und wie sehr dieser finanzielle Druck es verunmöglich, dass manche Menschen sich verwirklichen können. Und mit verwirklichen meine ich jetzt nicht irgendwas Spirituelles, sondern meine ich einfach, dass sie den Leidenschaften, die sie haben, wirklich nachgehen können. Also um das auf mich mal zu übertragen, ich komme ja aus kleinbürgerlichem Hause, also keine reichen Eltern und so habe aber ein ganz großes Glück gehabt, dass meine Eltern während meines Studiums mir so viel Geld gegeben haben, dass ich nicht einen Job nebenher machen musste. Ich habe aber dann auch, muss ich sagen, relativ bescheiden gelebt, weil ich dann dachte, naja, ich will mich ja auf meine kulturellen Dinge konzentrieren oder so. Ich bin dann nicht in Urlaub gefahren oder so was. Aber dadurch habe ich natürlich enorm viel Zeit gehabt, mich mit den Dingen, die mich interessieren, Philosophie, Literatur und so weiter, auseinanderzusetzen, während andere natürlich da zeitlich im Nachteil sind, die dann noch in der Woche 20 Stunden irgendwo arbeiten mussten. Und diese Situation des Zeitvorsprungs beziehungsweise Zeitnachsprungs, Zeit-Zeitnachteils, die haben wir ja ganz akut. Und da wäre tatsächlich auch nochmal ganz klar, ein Plädoyer für den Sozialstaat zu halten, wo eigentlich viel mehr Geld in die Hand genommen werden müsste. Du schlägst ja immer vor, dass man so ein Begrüßungsgeld mit dem Erwachsenenleben bekommt, dass man tatsächlich etwas mehr Unabhängigkeit hat. Vielleicht nicht ganz so viel wie die Influencerin, aber doch, dass man vielleicht sich viel mehr aussuchen kann, womit will ich mich eigentlich gerade beschäftigen?
Also Marcel Fratscher nennt das ja Lebenschancen-Erbe. Er hat das schon häufiger in seiner Zeitkolumne thematisiert. Piketty hat es ja auch vorgeschlagen. 100.000 Euro für jeden Europäer, der volljährig wird. Warum nicht? Denn die Kalkulation ist ja wie bei Sam Lessin. Man erreicht den Arbeitsmarkt und muss sich für ihn fit machen. Und dann ist die Frage, wie. Nimmt man gross Schulden auf und zahlt dann später Schuldgeld zurück und steuern oder bekommt man Geld? Und dann kann man ja eiskalt mal durchrechnen politisch, wie viel Steuereinnahmen sind denn zu erwarten von einer Durchschnittsperson? Dann wird das aufsummiert, die Hälfte abgezogen, damit auf jeden Fall ein Gewinn für den Staat, für die Gemeinschaft draus ist. Aber dann bekommt einfach jeder diesen Betrag ausgezahlt und danach über Steuerzahlung bringt man es zurück. So, und dann werden einige keine Steuern zahlen und manche werden sehr viel Steuern zahlen, denn wir haben ein progressives Steuersystem, das kann man ja alles so lassen. Also in der Sicht sind wir hier schon nah dran an so einer allgemeinen Realität. Wir haben sie noch nicht so organisiert oder so benannt. Klar, 1, 7 Millionen sind jetzt erst mal sehr viel, aber dafür eben auch handverlesen. Flächendeckend bringt man den Preis ein bisschen runter, aber das Prinzip ist ja trotzdem nicht verkehrt. Und deswegen finde ich es erstaunlich, dass wir auf der einen Seite hier mit einem ganz neuen Modell zu tun haben, das uns vorgestellt wird, das auf der anderen Seite schon relativ nah ist an so einer Realität, wie wir sie haben und er eben auch große große Freiräume einräumt. Also nicht nur sind es nur fünf Prozent an der Rendite, die er haben will und alles, was abseits des Creatertums an Einnahmen erzielt werden, sind außen vor, sondern selbst die Creator-Einnahmen werden noch mal mit einem Freibetrag ausgeführt.
Etwa ein paar Hunderttausend Dollar pro Jahr.
Wir wollen nicht monatisieren, dass es okay ist. Und das, was Leute anzudenken, was ich denke, wenn du Investoren bist, um die VC-Equationen zu bekommen, aber es ist schwer zu verstehen, dass es sehr wichtig ist, dass wir die Gewinner voll monetisieren können.
So, wenn man jetzt solche großen Freiräume einbekommt, dass die sagen, wir investieren in dich und in viele andere, wir wollen nur 5 Prozent, auch nur von Creator-Einnahmen und selbst die Creator-Einnahmen sind noch mal zu mehreren 100.000 pro Jahr frei, sodass wir wirklich nur bei den Gewinnern Gewinner abschöpfen und die kommen zu dem Schluss, das lohnt sich. Dann brauchen wir echt eine politische Debatte darüber, ob sich das nicht für jeden Menschen lohnt, ihn mit einem Lebenschancen-Erbe auszustatten, das staatlich organisiert und bereitgestellt wird. Denn hier scheint es doch irgendwie unglaubliche Spielräume zu geben.
Vermögenssteuerdebatte auch mit rein. Also das ist es ja dann am Ende. Also das sind Leute, die mehrere hunderttausende oder Millionen verdienen und ab dann greifen diese fünf Prozent, das ist dann Vermögensteuer, findet ja im Koalitionsvertrag keinen Platz, hat es mal wieder nicht geschafft. Aber es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass man eigentlich mit diesen fünf Prozent doch relativ viel erreichen könnte.
Ich meine, es gäbe jetzt unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten, darüber nachzudenken. Wir zahlen ja Renten aus, nachdem sie in Anführungszeichen erwirtschaftet wurden durch Einzahlung. Warum gibt es diese Rentenzahlung erst nach dem Berufsleben und nicht schon vorher, wo das Geld auch gebraucht wird und wo man noch was erleben kann? Mit 20 kann man Geld anders verwenden als mit 70. Wir haben beim Erbe keine Diskussion darüber, beim Einkommen allerdings schon, dass wir eine negative Einkommenssteuer haben. Das ist ja eine dieser bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen-Modelle, dass wir eine negative Einkommenssteuer haben im Sinne von, also wir garantieren erstmal ein Einkommen, wenn man das nicht erreicht, kriegt man eine negative Einkommenssteuer, bis es erreicht ist auf dem Niveau. Wenn man da drüber liegt, bezahlt man Einkommenssteuer, dass da ein Ausgleich stattfindet. Wir haben das bei dem Erbe auf jeden Fall, also als Idee, aber sollten wir auch als Diskussion haben. Erbe für alle, höhere Erben werden dann besteuert, zu kleine Erben werden angepasst auf diesen Ausgangsbetrag. Also da kann man unglaublich viel machen. Gut, das wird jetzt erstmal alles hier privat organisiert, ist auch erstmal nur ein Einzelfall. Ich glaube, das ist die erste Creatorin, die sie da finanzieren, aber sie zieht das ja auf, als wir wollen das große Feld, und dann werden wir uns die Gewinner daraus picken. Zumindest sieht er sich ja in der Cäsur als Pionier so unglaublich, wie wir es damals fanden und heute eben nicht mehr. Dass irgendwelche Leute hingehen und sagen, diese Business-Idee gefällt mir, ich zahle dir jetzt drei Milliarden Dollar. Also diese Art von Venture-Capital ist ja mittlerweile total normal in Amerika und Europa immer noch so, ja keine Ahnung, braucht man mal einen Staat, der uns irgendwie hilft. Und er möchte, also Sam Lessin, dass dieses neue Finanzierungsmodell für Creator irgendwann mal so selbstverständlich wird, wie das bisherige Venture-Capital.
und Konsumenten-Investitionen anschaut, ein komisches Nische-Titel, das auf der Westküste gemacht wurde, wo keiner die finanziellen Modelle verstanden hat.
Venture-Capitalist, die eine Meinung darüber hatten, können aber viel Geld machen.
Aber wie in jeder guten Industrie, jetzt versteht jeder die Modelle.
Die Hedge-Funds kommen in wie verrückt.
Unser Job als echte Venture-Capitalisten ist, die neuen Dinge zu finden, wo es einen Kapital-Gap gibt, in dem die Leute Geld nutzen können, um tolle Dinge zu machen, aber nicht zu bekommen.
Ja, also er sieht die ganzen Sachen, die man so braucht, schon wieder als Commodity, die sind einfach selbstverständlich. Und jetzt sieht er sich als der real Venture Capitalist, der einfach nur noch in die Idee, in die Person investiert. Mal gucken, wie das weitergeht.
Man darf gespannt sein und wir können auf jeden Fall schon mal festhalten, dass es jetzt den Vermögenden noch mal besser gehen wird. Also es wird sich...
Da sind auch neue Rendite-Möglichkeiten.
Da sind neue Rendite-Möglichkeiten und die Mitte wird nicht entlastet, weil das immer so gesagt wurde jetzt. Die Mitte wird an keiner Stelle entlastet.
Wenn man sowas hier privat organisiert, weiß man auch, da wird halt Handverlesen und die große Mehrheit bleibt dann leer aus. Aber wie gesagt, da steckt irgendwie Gedankenmaterial für eine politische Agenda drin, finde ich. Denn wenn die da eine Rendite-Chance sehen, dann sollten wir die gesamtgesellschaftlich erst recht irgendwie sehen. Gut, ein kleines Thema noch mit drei Clips. Klima, und zwar nur, weil ich mich chronistenpflichtig hier, November war ja Klimamonat, wir hatten ja die Glasgow Klimakonferenz, die mal wieder zu nichts gekommen ist, wenn man den politischen und moralischen Beobachtungen folgt.
Aber auch eine merkwürdige Berichterstattung. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es im ZDF oder in der ARD war. Ich schaute die Nachrichten und die erste Frage, die an die Korrespondentin ging, war ist das jetzt für die Klimakonferenz ein großes Problem, dass die Queen nicht persönlich erscheinen wird? Und ich denke mir, was soll man von der Queen erwarten, wenn die dort erschienen wäre? Ja, schöne Bilder. Also eigentlich wäre das so eine Frage, die hätte man an die Redaktion stellen können. Sag mal, ist das eigentlich für uns heute Abend ein Problem, wenn wir jetzt keine Bilder der Queen zeigen können, könnten wir dann über Inhalte berichten? Oder was sollen wir dann vorwiegendes tun? Aber das eine Korrespondentin zu fragen, fand ich nun wirklich absurd.
Ja, im Fernsehen steckte nichts dazu drin, außer dass die großen Fische nicht kamen. Nicht nur die Queen musste absagen, sondern auch G und Putin wollten alle nicht aufs Parkett mit Boris Johnson. Denn der Typ dreht ja auch immer so ein bisschen durch, da weiß man ja nie, was da passiert. Und deswegen war die Berichterstattung wie sie war. Man muss trotzdem wahrscheinlich sagen, dass sie in Sachen Green Finance sehr viel weitergekommen ist, also die Welt-Community in Sachen Klima, als jetzt der Berichterstattung da zu entnehmen war. Zumindest läuft ja gerade diese große Taxonomie der EU-Kommission, die jetzt wirklich Green Finance, also den Katalog einfach, welches Investment titeln wir, also kategorisieren wir unter Grün, fördern das dann auch entsprechend und was hauen wir da raus und so. Das ist ja wirklich alles in der Mache. Wenn auch unklar ist, wie weit das dann wirklich Klima rettet und so. Im Fernsehen war es trotzdem ganz interessant. Wir gucken drei kleine Clips aus Lanz-Sendungen. Markus Lanz hatte nämlich Harald Lesch zu Gast. Und er hat uns mal hier in Sachen gesteigerter Verbrauch, unendlicher Verbrauch, Verbrauch, Verbrauch und so weiter. Also diese Wälzer-Idee von wir verbrauchen alle zu viel. Ist ja nicht gänzlich falsch, wenn auch falsch im Sinne von...
Es ist halt die Frage, ob man das von einer einsamen Insel als hochdotierter Professor und Bestsellerautor mal allen zu rufen soll. Das gilt aber auch nicht für sich selbst. Also das ist ja, ich glaube diese, ich bin ja sehr dagegen, dass man immer so individualistische Kritik laufend übt. Und man kann jetzt auch nicht jedem ständig in den Einkaufswagen gucken und sagen, oh, das geht aber gar nicht. Das ist aber nicht klimafreundlich. Aber ich beobachte doch immer mehr, wie diese ganzen Moralapostel dann selbst komplett anders leben. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was sehr viele Leute in Deutschland auch merken und sich dann fragen, ja, bin ich denn bescheuert und halte mich jetzt da etwa dran. Ähnlich wie wir das eben schon mal mit den Lockdown-Befürwortern thematisiert haben, die permanent im Fernsehen auftreten und die ich jetzt zum Teil auch schon gesehen habe, jetzt ja in der vergangenen Monate und immer irgendwie denke, ja, das deckt sich irgendwie nicht mit dem, was ich bei Twitter so von dir in den letzten Wochen und Monaten gelesen habe.
Genau, wir haben die Gurus und ihre Mantras und wissen, es sind alles Lügen und wir haben über die Innenstädte gesprochen. Wir können sehr viel wirtschaftlichen Mehrwert draus schöpfen, ohne dass wir die ganze Zeit Material verbrauchen, sondern, das kann ich jetzt sagen, mit drei Kindern, es geht vor allem um Erlebnisse, wie Achterbahnfahrt und so weiter. Ja, die kostet auch ein bisschen Strom, aber nichts im Vergleich zu das tolle Shopping-Erlebnis von Günther, wenn er sich seinen neuen Mercedes abholt. Also da sind doch einige Chancen zu holen und wir werden hier mal auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückgeholt. Wie viel Strom verbrauchen wir eigentlich, wenn wir uns das mal verbildlichen? Lesch, der Professor, Physiker sitzt also da und findet Äquivalente, um unseren Stromverbrauch vorzuführen.
Sie machen das Beispiel des Radfahrers, da sehen wir auch die Grafik dazu. Da ist dieser arme Mann, wobei man sagen muss, bei den Oberschenkeln kann man auch mal ein bisschen trainieren, der tritt also 10 Stunden 100 Watt.
Die ganze Zeit 100 Watt. Nach 10 Stunden hat er dann eine Kilowattstunde, die ist 30 Cent wert und hat die Energiemenge von 100 Milliliter Benzin.
10 Stunden 100 Watt reicht für eine Kilowattstunde, aus 30 Cent kriegt man ein Zehntel Liter Benzin dafür. Da weiß man ja, wie weit man damit kommt. 100 Watt auf dem Fahrrad ist ja ungefähr das, was der Durchschnittsdeutsche wahrscheinlich 10 Stunden schafft. Dreimal so viel werden dann schon austrainierte Triathleten stärker und so. Also wir sind wirklich gefesselt. Das ist unsere Leistungsfähigkeit. Sehr viel ist da nicht rauszuholen. Was kann man jetzt nach 10 Stunden Fahrradfahren mit 100 Watt energetisch rausholen für sich?
Der strampelt 10 Stunden.
Damit kann man drei Minuten duschen.
Tja, drei Minuten duschen. Das ist aber echt wenig.
Da muss man sich sehr beeilen. Ja, das schaffe ich nicht in drei Minuten.
So, und jetzt hatten wir ja schon mal diese Idee von unserem ehemaligen, bald ehemaligen Entwicklungsminister Müller. Und er meinte ja, für jeden von uns arbeiten 50 Sklaven irgendwo auf der Welt, über die Lieferketten organisiert. Irgendwer strampelt sich für uns ab. So, und jetzt haben wir auf der Sozialdimension, okay, für uns arbeiten irgendwo 50 Sklaven. Jetzt auf der sachlichen Dimension, Klima und so weiter. Wie viele Leute fahren eigentlich für uns Fahrrad, für jeden Einzelnen von uns?
Die gesamte Energiemenge in Deutschland dividiert durch die 80 Millionen und 365 Tage. Das macht 120 Kilowattstunden pro Person und Tag.
Das heißt, jeder von uns hat 120 gedankliche Radfahrer, die irgendwo...
Da sieht man ja, eine Mahlzeit ist eine Kilowattstunde, drei Minuten duschen, eine 60 Grad Wäsche, zehn Stunden Glühlampe, die gibt es ja nicht mehr, 60 Stunden LED. Das ist das, was eine Kilowattstunde...
Und jetzt kommt Frank Thelen und sagt, machbar, Technologie haben wir drauf.
Wie? Na ja, haben wir drauf. Wir müssen natürlich auch noch viel entwickeln, aber wir müssen vor allem auch investieren in diese Technologien. Und wenn man so was sieht wie moderne Atomkraft, also Atomkraft 4.0 oder Kernfusion, dann glaube ich schon, dass wir dazu eine Chance haben.
Ja, gar nicht, ich will nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben, in der Frank Thelen zu irgendwas befragt wird. Wirklich, das ist doch... Das kann doch nicht sein, dass das das Niveau der Debatte ist. Also wie kann es sein, wie kann es sein, dass der laufend im Fernsehen sitzt? Das ist doch...
Also für alle, die sich dafür interessieren, was sagt Harald Lesch zu Frank Thelens Atomkraft 4.0? Empfehle ich diese Sendung, denn es wird kurz und klein geschlagen, es bleibt nichts davon übrig. Atomkraft ist kein Ausweg. Aber wir halten hier fest, für uns arbeiten 50 Sklaven irgendwo auf der Welt, um unsere materiellen Güter zu holen. Und für unsere energetischen Güter fahren 120 Leute für uns Fahrrad 10 Stunden. Das ist das Äquivalent ungefähr. Das ist einfach, wir leben völlig über unsere Verhältnisse. Das kann man schon mal sagen. Wir müssen da ein bisschen was tun. Naja, aber ich meine, was soll man sagen, so ist es.
Du fährst ja wenigstens noch Fahrrad. Ich fahre ja gar kein Fahrrad.
Ich fahre nur Fahrrad, da ich ja keinen Führerschein habe. Nö, ich habe mich noch nie schuldig gemacht, Auto zu fahren. Ja, so ist es.
Ja, ich hatte damals ja mit dem Fahrradfahren aufgehört, als ich den Führerschein hatte.
Ja, nein, ich kann Fahrradfahren sehr empfehlen. Das macht nicht nur fit, sondern hält auch die Laune aufrecht. Man sieht ja ungefähr, wie die Leute drauf sind, die abends mit dem Auto nach Hause fahren.
So weit es geht, wo man zum Teil mit dem Fahrrad gar nicht hinkommt. Und ich muss ja sagen, ich komme ja mit den Anzügen, kann ich ja kein Fahrrad fahren. Wie soll das gehen?
Du hast da eine Ausrede.
Brauche ich da andere Klamotten? Und dann müsste ich wieder konsumieren. Das ist also gar nicht gut.
Sehr gut. So, dann haben wir alle Clips geguckt. Ich habe noch mal in der Liste geguckt. Nein, es ist nichts weiter offen, was unbedingt gespielt werden muss. Damit ist der November verhandelt, würde ich sagen.
Und wir sehen uns im Salon. Ich hoffe, ich bin dann schon wieder mehr bei Stimme. Bin dann wieder gesund. Das ist ja erst in einer Woche. Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das Ende der Arbeit gekommen ist oder ob es doch noch weitergeht.
Sehr gut. Genau das machen wir. Wir gehen ganz sensibel an dieses Thema ran.
Ach ja, Flasspöler, präsentierst du uns ja auch noch. Da bin ich sehr gespannt.
Ich verlinke jetzt in diesem Podcast unseren Instagram-Account mit. Da kann man nachgucken, denn alle aktuellen Sachen werden wir wahrscheinlich dort dann einfach, wie man das halt so macht, man schickt irgendein Bild von sich und schreibt dann das, was man sagen will, einfach drunter. Es ist nun mal eine Bilderplattform, aber in der geht es trotzdem um Text. Da werden wir dann auch alle Bücher ankündigen, zum Beispiel noch mal den Grabber, den wir dann im Januar oder Februar, je nachdem, wie man auf Deutsch davor liegt und so weiter. Das kann man dann danach schauen. Sehr gut, damit haben wir alles gesagt, in November ausführlich verhandelt. Wir gehen jetzt kein Schnittel essen, denn du gehst jetzt ins Bett und trinkst noch einen Tee.
So ist es. Bis dann.